Some trips are just better in an Airbnb. And right now you can discover Canada and their many local hidden gems with an Airbnb. I worked in Canada off and on for two years. Yes. And my first year, the production put me up at a place. And the second year, I was like, hey, whatever that production budget is,
有些旅行，住Airbnb就是更爽。現在你就可以透過Airbnb，探索加拿大以及當地無數的隱藏寶石。我在加拿大斷斷續續工作了兩年。沒錯。我的第一年，劇組幫我安排了一個住所。到了第二年，我想說，嘿，不管那筆製作預算有多少，
can I have it and go find my own place in more of a neighborhood, you know? Yes. And I did, I got an Airbnb, I got a little apartment, it faced a park, it was so lovely. I loved the host and I stayed there for two months. Wow. Yeah, and I was near a grocery store.
能不能給我，讓我去找個比較有社區感覺的地方，你知道嗎？沒錯。而我真的這麼做了，我租了一間Airbnb，有一間小公寓，剛好面對著一座公園，真是太棒了。我很喜歡房東，在那裡住了兩個月。哇。對啊，而且附近就有一家雜貨店。
I really felt like I made a little life there. I'm thinking about like the Rocky Mountain areas in Canada where they've got the lakes and the Alberta Rockies. I don't know, it just feels like if you got yourself a cozy little cabin there. You know what I mean? Yeah. Like Banff National Park.
我真的覺得自己在那裡過上了小日子。我在想加拿大的洛磯山脈一帶，那裡有湖泊和亞伯達洛磯山脈。不知道，就覺得如果你在那裡弄間舒適的小木屋。你知道我的意思嗎？對啊。就像班夫國家公園。
Well listen, maybe you should consider Airbnb for your next adventure. I mean, we love it. Love it. What's better than a well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue? A well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue that was carefully selected by an Instacart shopper and delivered to your door. A well-marbled ribeye you ordered without even leaving the kiddie pool. Whatever groceries your summer calls for, Instacart has you covered. Download the Instacart app and enjoy $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Instacart, groceries that
聽著，或許你該考慮把Airbnb當作你下次冒險的選擇。我是說，我們超愛。超愛。有什麼比在大烤爐上滋滋作響的大理石紋肋眼牛排更棒的呢？一塊由Instacart採購員精心挑選並送到你家門口、在大烤爐上滋滋作響的大理石紋肋眼牛排。一塊你甚至不用離開戲水池就能下單的大理石紋肋眼牛排。不管你夏天需要什麼雜貨，Instacart都能滿足你。下載Instacart應用程式，前三筆訂單即可享有0美元外送費。適用服務費、排除條款與條件。Instacart，超乎期待的
over deliver. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details, and lots of VFF stories. We're the Office Ladies 6.0. Hello! Hi there!
雜貨外送。我是珍娜·費捨，我是安琪拉·金西。我們曾一起出演《辦公室瘋雲》，而且我們是最好的朋友。現在我們為你專門製作了這個終極辦公室愛好者Podcast。每週我們都會深入探討《辦公室瘋雲》的世界，帶來獨家訪談、幕後花絮以及大量的VFF故事。我們是《辦公室辦公室女郎》6.0。哈囉！大家好！
Hi! Ooh, we have some special guests today. We do. This is the most we have some special guests today. We do. This is the most we've ever talked on the podcast as a group. You've never had five people. No. Correct.
嗨！噢，我們今天有一些特別來賓。沒錯。這真的是我們...我們今天有一些特別來賓。沒錯。這絕對是我們在Podcast裡以團體形式聊得最多的一次。你們從來沒有過五個人。對。沒錯。
Angela, do you want to tell everybody what's happening? I sure do. We have a super fun episode today because we are doing a crossover with Pod Meets World. We have Ryder, Danielle, and Will from Boy Meets World. We each got to watch an episode of each other's show. Yes. Yes.
安琪拉，你想跟大家說說發生了什麼事嗎？我當然想。我們今天有一集超級有趣的節目，因為我們要跟《男生世界》進行聯動。我們有來自《男生世界》的萊德、丹妮爾和威爾。我們各自看了一集彼此的節目。對。對。
OK, Jenna, why don't you share with everyone how this episode came about? OK, well, Ryder and I know each other. Yeah. That's how this came about. Yeah. How do you guys know each other? Yes.
好了，珍娜，你何不跟大家分享一下這一集是怎麼促成的呢？好的，呃，萊德跟互相認識。對。事情就是這樣促成的。對。你們怎麼認識彼此的？對。
We have a mutual friend in Natalie's Z. Party's at her house, right? How far you guys go back? So Travis Schult is friends with my husband Lee. Okay, so it's Travis. Okay, okay. Travis, who is married to Natalie. Travis and Natalie will have a party here and there,
我們有一個共同的朋友叫娜塔莉·Z。派對在她家開，對吧？你們認識多久了？所以崔維斯·舒爾特跟我老公李是朋友。好吧，所以是崔維斯。好吧，好吧。崔維斯，他娶了娜塔莉。崔維斯和娜塔莉偶爾會辦個派對，
and you're there and I'm there. One of the first people I talked to about Pod Meets World when I was back, because I was like, how's your re-watch podcast going? And you were super helpful and you were like, do it. You'll have the best time, it's so good. And yeah, you were like one of the people that really convinced me that this was a
然後你在那裡，我也在那裡。我剛回歸時，第一個跟我聊到《男生世界》這檔Podcast的人之一就是你，因為我當時就在想：「你們的重看Podcast進行得怎麼樣啊？」而你超級幫忙，你就說：「做就對了。你們會玩得最開心，這節目太棒了。」然後，對啊，你就是那種真正說服我這是一個
great idea. Oh, good. Oh, I'm so glad. Well, your podcast is super successful. They guys have an amazing community. You guys are real friends in real life like me and Angela. Yes, you do a fantastic job telling the show, telling all the scenes and what goes on behind. I think it's just such a great podcast. And I really am so curious to watch more episodes now. Truly, truly. Especially now that I know some of the things you can share with us.
好主意的人之一。噢，太好了。噢，我太高興了。話說回來，你們的Podcast超級成功的。你們有一群超棒的粉絲社群。你們就像我和安琪拉一樣，在現實生活中是真正的朋友。沒錯，你們在節目中表現得太棒了，講述了所有的場景以及幕後發生的事情。我覺得這真是一檔非常棒的Podcast。現在我真的非常好奇，想看更多集了。真的，真的。特別是現在我知道了一些你們可以跟我們分享的事情。
Oh, yeah. A little trivia. How did we get there? Yeah. Yes, yes, because full disclosure, Angela and I had not seen an episode of Boy Meets World until this collab happened. I think similarly, Ryder, had you ever seen an episode of Boy Meets World until this collab happened. I think similarly, Ryder,
噢，對。一些冷知識。我們是怎麼走到這一步的？對。沒錯，沒錯，因為坦白說，在這次合作之前，安琪拉和我都沒看過半集《男生世界》。我想同樣地，萊德，在這次合作之前，你有看過半集《男生世界》嗎？我想同樣地，萊德，
had you ever seen an episode of The Office? Yeah, I had only watched probably the first two seasons. Okay. Maybe up to three. So you had not seen the episode we picked for today then. No, no. Will has seen every episode of The Office numerous times. Oh. I'm also a little weird when it comes to TV,
你有看過任何一集的《辦公室瘋雲》嗎？有啊，我大概只看過前兩季吧。好吧。可能到第三季。所以你當時並沒有看我們今天挑選的那一集囉？沒有，沒有。威爾看過無數次《辦公室瘋雲》的每一集。噢。對於電視節目，我也有點奇怪，
so if I see it more than once, I can recite it backwards and forwards. So I watched the episode again, you had us watch, but I didn't need to. I could have literally told you what you were wearing, usually in most of the scenes. Wow. He knew it very well.
所以只要我看過一次以上，我就能倒背如流。所以我又看了一遍你們讓我看的這一集，但我其實不需要看。我literally可以告訴你每個人穿什麼衣服，通常在大多數的場景裡都是如此。哇。他對這集非常熟悉。
You're like a genius person. With TV. Photographic memory on TV. Wow. Yeah, with TV. So like, if I have nothing to do and I'm bored and there's nothing around me, I shut my eyes and watch MASH. Come on. It's true. Back, with TV. So, like, if I have nothing to do and I'm bored and there's nothing around me, I shut my eyes and watch MASH.
你簡直是個天才。對電視節目。對電視節目有過目不忘的記憶力。哇。對，對電視節目。所以，如果我沒事做、覺得無聊，周圍又什麼都沒有，我就會閉上眼，看《 M*A*S*H 》。拜託。真的。回過頭來，對電視節目。所以，如果我沒事做、覺得無聊，周圍又什麼都沒有，我就會閉上眼，看《 M*A*S*H 》。
Come on. Because you can just play that in your head. And the images are there as well as the... The images, the sound, the music, the breaks. But if he doesn't have his giant calendar in front of him, he can't remember what there is to do or whether or not something is scheduled. My wife helps, but no, I don't know. So TV, selective genius. There's a little bit of undercurrent business happening in this conversation.
拜託。因為你可以在腦海中播放它。影像和聲音都在那裡…… 影像、聲音、音樂、過場。但如果他面前沒有那個巨大的行事曆，他就記不住有什麼事要做，或者某件事是不是已經排好了行程。我老婆會幫忙，但沒錯，我不知道。所以電視是選擇性天才。這段對話背後其實隱藏著一些潛台詞。
They just know not to ask anymore. Be here such and such a time and she'll text my wife. They also just say, could you just take a picture of the big calendar? Because I understand that you can't care. It's a literal giant calendar. We also just say, could you just take a picture of the big calendar? Because I understand that you can't care. It's a literal giant calendar. So I'll say, because if you just had the picture of it, you'd know if you were free on the eighth. This is a really good idea. So did you take a picture of your calendar?
他們只是知道不要再問了。幾點幾分到這裡，她會傳訊息給我老婆。他們也會直接說：「你可以拍一下大行事曆的照片嗎？」因為我理解你根本不在乎。那真的是一個巨大的行事曆。我們也經常直接說：「你可以拍一下大行事曆的照片嗎？因為我理解你根本不在乎。那真的是一個巨大的行事曆。」所以我會說，因為只要你有它的照片，你就會知道自己初八有沒有空。這真是一個好主意。所以你有拍你行事曆的照片嗎？
I think the last one I took was in April. Yeah. So I have to leave where I'm supposed to be. Otherwise they just tell me where I'm supposed to be. You guys, we are actually in your studio today. It's lovely, and there are cameras. I feel like they could make a video for you of your calendar that you would watch,
我想我拍的最後一張是在四月。對。所以我必須離開我該去的地方。否則他們只會告訴我我該去哪裡。各位，我們今天其實是在你們的錄音室裡。這裡很可愛，而且有攝影機。我覺得他們可以幫你的行事曆做一段影片給你看，
and then you would know everything. That's not a bad idea. I'd know where I'd have to be and all the stuff I had to do. Again, comes to episodes of The Office all day long, where I have to be tomorrow, anybody's guess. I feel like you could be a really good asset for office ladies. What would you like to know? I mean, they tomorrow, anybody's guess. I feel like you could be a really good asset for office ladies.
然後你就會什麼都知道了。這主意不賴。我就會知道我得去哪裡，以及所有我必須做的事。話說回來，如果是《辦公室瘋雲》的集數，我可以倒背如流；但明天我得去哪裡，誰也說不準。我覺得你可以成為「辦公室女郎」節目的一個很好用的資產。你想知道什麼？我是說，他們明天要去哪裡，誰也說不準。我覺得你可以成為「辦公室女郎」節目的一個很好用的資產。
What would you like to know? I mean, I mean, we're gonna hit you up. Okay, great. I mean, yeah. Please, let me know. Be happy to. I'll walk you through it.
你想知道什麼？我是說，我是說，我們會找你幫忙的。好的，太棒了。我是說，對。拜託，讓我知道。我很樂意。我會帶你了解。
It's a great show. Thank you. Not to belabor this, but I am really fascinated. Does this extend as well to things you've read, books, articles? It depends on what, if it's stuck in my brain, it's forever stuck in my brain.
這是一部很棒的節目。謝謝。話雖如此，但我真的很好奇。這也適用於你讀過的東西嗎，像是書本、文章？這取決於是什麼，如果它卡在我的腦海裡，就會永遠卡在我的腦海裡。
And I can go back and see the page, see the thing. But then again, a calculia is a very real thing. So put two numbers in front of me and my brain doesn't comprehend them. You also in school wouldn't take notes. You would just watch the teacher. I could, because if I look down to take notes. If you look down, you wouldn't.
然後我可以倒回去看那個頁面、看那個東西。但話說回來，算術障礙（dyscalculia）是一件非常真實的事情。所以只要把兩個數字放在我面前，我的大腦就無法理解它們。你在學校也不會做筆記。你只會看著老師。我可以，因為如果我低頭做筆記。如果你低頭，你就不會。
But if he just listened and watched it. If I listened and just watched the board, then I could just see the board. No, but again, if somebody gave me a phone number or people's names, I have to meet somebody a thousand times before I remember their names. But I can see the blue shirt you're wearing. I can see the shirt you walk in on when,
但如果他只是聽和看。如果我聽著然後只看著黑板，那我就可以看著黑板。不，但話說回來，如果有人給我一個電話號碼或別人的名字，我必須見一個人一千次才能記住他們的名字。但我能看到你身上穿的藍色襯衫。我能看到你走進來時穿的那件襯衫，
fashion show, fashion show at lunch. I can see the color of the pew show. You guys should quiz him. You should ask him the shirt. Wow, if you remember a certain line or moment. Yeah, so stuff like that. It's so crazy because we just did a side-by-side. A fan wrote in and said that they think that Josh
時尚秀，午餐時的時尚秀。我能看到長椅秀的顏色。你們應該考考他。你們應該問他那件襯衫。哇，如果你還記得某句台詞或某個時刻。對，就是類似這樣的事情。這太瘋狂了，因為我們剛好做了一個對比。有粉絲寫信來說，他們覺得史丹佛的
and Stamford is wearing the same suit that Michael Scott wears on his birthday. And I had to go and look at both episodes and take a picture of each one and make a side-by-side. And it's not the same suit. No, it's not the same suit. Birthday episode is when he goes and plays hockey with the blue shirt and the blue tie. Yeah. Yeah, no, that's not. Holy cow. It's not exactly the same suit. That's not the same suit. No, it's not the same suit. Birthday episode is when he goes and plays hockey with the blue shirt and the blue tie.
喬許穿的西裝跟麥可·史考特在他生日那天穿的西裝是一樣的。我不得不去看這兩集的內容，給每一集拍張照片，然後做一個對比。結果根本不是同一套西裝。不，不是同一套西裝。生日那一集是他去打冰球，穿著藍襯衫和藍領帶。對。對，不是那樣。天啊。根本不是同一套西裝。那不是同一套西裝。不，不是同一套西裝。生日那一集是他去打冰球，穿著藍襯衫和藍領帶。
Yeah. Yeah, no, that's not. Holy cow. It's not exactly the same suit. That's not the same suit. No, no, no. And also, which episode are you talking about with Josh from Stanford? Is this, you don't snipe in Carrington.
對。對，不是那樣。天啊。根本不是同一套西裝。那不是同一套西裝。不，不是同一套西裝。不，不，不。還有，你說的是史丹佛的喬許的哪一集啊？這是……你沒有在卡林頓開玩笑吧？
Oh, is it the initiation? Was it the initiation? Which is right before Diwali. A branch closing. Branch closing, oh, is when you leveraged the promotion to do another offer. That was the branch closing. Okay. So when Jen's like, I've driven something like 400 miles today.
噢，是那集新員工入職訓練嗎？是新員工入職訓練嗎？就在排燈節之前的那集。分公司關閉。分公司關閉，噢，就是你利用升職去談另一個offer的那集。那是分公司關閉。好吧。所以當珍說：「我今天開了大概400英哩的車。」
So I'm just going to say this. That one. I think that one. Yeah. So he has a pinstripe suit on and a bright blue shirt, which is similar to Michael's birthday. He does, but it's a different, it's wider pinstripes than Michael's. And the tie is different.
所以我只想說這個。就是那一集。我覺得是那一集。對。所以他穿著一件細條紋西裝和一件亮藍色襯衫，跟麥可生日那套很像。他確實穿那樣，但那是不同的……條紋比麥可的寬。而且領帶也不一樣。
The tie is different as well. Yeah. Why do I need to do side by side photos anymore? You don't. Just call Will. Just call Will. A new resource. I mean, yeah, that's not. If I ever decided to use this for evil.
領帶也不一樣。對。為什麼我還要再做對比照片啊？你不用了。直接打給威爾。直接打給威爾。一個新資源。我是說，對，那不是。如果我哪天決定用這個能力來作惡。
We don't even want to go down that path because it'd be be pretty dangerous. Yeah. Wow. Yeah. Don't come at me, trivia night at a bar. If it was an office themed trivia night. Like I win Jeopardy most nights night at a bar. Yeah. Oh, trivia like, like. If it was an office themed trivia night. Like, I win Jeopardy most nights. Oh, wow. Yeah, I know a lot.
我們甚至不想走那條路，因為那會相當危險。對。哇。對，酒吧裡的冷知識之夜，可別來挑戰我。如果那是個《辦公室瘋雲》主題的冷知識之夜的話。就像我大部分晚上都能贏《危險邊緣》一樣。酒吧裡的夜晚。對。噢，冷知識之夜，像是。如果那是個《辦公室瘋雲》主題的冷知識之夜。就像我大部分晚上都能贏《危險邊緣》一樣。噢，哇。對，我懂很多。
You have to go on Jeopardy. I know. I don't know if I'd be able to. Celebrity Jeopardy. Running in would be the weird part for me. I don't know if I'd. Oh, the buzzer. I was asked to do it one year and I freaked out.
你得去上《危險邊緣》。我知道。我不知道自己能不能行。名人版《危險邊緣》。跑上台對我來說會是最奇怪的部分。我不知道我是不是……噢，按鈴。我有一年被邀請去上節目，然後我嚇壞了。
I was like, I could lose. I'm a teen celebrity Jeopardy. I was like, I don't want to go beat Melissa Joan Harden in Jeopardy. Just make me feel bad. So yeah. All right, you guys. Pod Meets World is a fantastic rewatch podcast of the hit show Boy Meets World. It premiered on ABC in 1993.
我當時想：「我可能會輸。我可是青少年名人版《危險邊緣》選手耶。」我當時心想：「我才不要去在《危險邊緣》節目上被梅麗莎·瓊·哈特打敗。」那會讓我感覺很糟。所以，對。好了，各位。《男生世界》是一檔非常棒的重看Podcast，節目探討的是熱門影集《男生世界》。它於1993年在ABC首播。
Yeah. Oh my goodness. It ran until 2000. All three of you guys were on it. And over the course of the run, the show received numerous awards and nominations. And in 2020, Boy Meets World won online film and television Hall of Fame Award for television programs. Really?
對。噢天哪。一直播到2000年。你們三個人都有演出。而在播出期間，這部影集獲得了無數的獎項和提名。而在2020年，《男生世界》贏得了線上影視名人堂獎的電視節目獎。真的嗎？
What? When did we win? What? According to IMDb. You guys, 2020 Hall of Fame. Your show Hall of Fame Award. Wow. Why weren't we invited?
什麼？我們什麼時候得獎的？什麼？根據IMDb的說法。各位，2020年名人堂。你們的節目獲得名人堂獎。哇。我們怎麼沒被邀請？
I wonder if no one sent us even a screenshot. I'd like to thank Fame Award. Wow. Why weren't we invited? No one sent us even a screenshot. I'd like to thank my parents. Exactly. Wow, that's cool. I'd like to bring up the fact that we were all five on long running hit television shows. Amazing. But there was a big difference.
我在想是不是連個截圖都沒有人寄給我們。我要感謝名人堂獎。哇。我們怎麼沒被邀請？連個截圖都沒有人寄給我們。我要感謝我的父母。沒錯。哇，這太酷了。我想提出一個事實，我們這五個人都演過長期播出的熱門電視影集。太驚人了。但這中間有一個巨大的差異。
Y'all were kids. Yeah. So can you tell us how old were each of you when the show started and then when it ended? I was from 12 to 19. Okay. 13 to 20. 16 to 24.
你們當時都是孩子。對。所以你們能不能告訴我們，節目剛開播和結束時，你們各自幾歲？我從12歲到19歲。好吧。13到20歲。16到24歲。
Wow. Yeah. Yep. Wow. And also filmed in front of a studio audience. Yes. Which is different. Very wonderful.
哇。對。沒錯。哇。而且還是在攝影棚現場觀眾面前拍攝的。沒錯。這很不一樣。非常美妙。
Very few episodes where we would not have an audience. Two or three, right? I think a handful. Yeah, but it was, oh God, there's nothing like show night. Yeah, so much more like theater. Yeah. Yeah. And especially when you're on a younger god, there's nothing like show night. Yeah, so much more like theater. Yeah. Yeah.
只有極少數幾集我們沒有現場觀眾。兩三集吧？我想也就幾集吧。對，但那種感覺，噢天哪，沒有什麼比得上演出之夜的。對，更像是戲劇演出。對。對。而且特別是當你出演一部更……噢天哪，沒有什麼比得上演出之夜的。對，更像是戲劇演出。對。對。
And especially when you're on a younger show, especially when we're starting to get popular, I'm putting that in quotes, because we were never really that popular when we were on. It was later we became popular, but kids would line up. So it'd be 14 and 15 year olds just screaming all night long. And it was, it's such a rush. It was really great. Yeah.
而且特別是當你出演一部比較年輕的節目，特別是當我們開始變得受歡迎時，我把這詞加上引號，因為我們演的時候其實從來沒有那麼受歡迎。那是後來我們才變紅的，但當時孩子們會大排長龍。所以整晚都是14、15歲的小孩在尖叫。那種感覺，真是一陣狂喜。真的超棒的。對。
That must've been such a buzz in the room. Oh god, it was so fun. You know, our soundstage was really quiet. And you were happy if buzz in the room. Oh god. It was so fun You know our sound stage was really quiet and yeah You were happy if you saw the boom mic guy shake a little bit Yeah, like I got him. I got him. Yeah, but otherwise it was pretty quiet except for us breaking I was gonna say you must have wanted to break each other just to just to get that Do you not watch the outtakes of the office? I love when you're making each other laugh, but when the dialogue's so funny that you're making yourself laugh,
那房間裡的氣氛一定超嗨的。噢天哪，真的超好玩的。你知道，我們的錄影棚其實很安靜。而且如果你看到收音桿收音員稍微晃動一下，你就會很高興，心想：「耶，我逗笑他了。我逗笑他了。」對，但除此之外，除了我們自己笑場之外，其實還蠻安靜的。我是說，你們當時一定很想看彼此笑場，只是為了……你們沒有看過《辦公室瘋雲》的NG片段嗎？我超愛看你們把彼此逗笑的樣子，但當台詞實在太好笑，搞得你們自己都笑場的時候，
that's one of my favorite things in the world, where you can't even get through the line because they're so good. I think you're talking about Wayne Wilson. He would crack himself up all the time. All the time, all the time. Well, wait, so when we were on Pod Meets World, we were watching the Boy Meets World episode,
那真的是我這輩子最愛的情景之一，你們甚至因為台詞太棒而無法順利把台詞念完。我想你說的是韋恩·威爾遜。他總是把自己逗笑。總是這樣，總是這樣。好吧，等等，所以當我們在《男生世界》的Podcast上時，我們看的是《男生世界》的那集，
hair today, goon tomorrow, and today we are watching The Surplus from The Office. And speaking of bloopers, I think one of the hardest times I ever laughed in a scene was when Dwight gives Andy and Angela directions to... Oh, gosh. So many cases to hear the beehives. That's a great blooper.
《今日頭髮，明日白痴》，而今天我們看的是《辦公室瘋雲》的《剩餘預算》。說到NG鏡頭，我覺得我拍戲時笑得最慘的一次，就是當德懷特給安迪和安琪拉指路去……噢，天哪。有無數次聽到蜂巢的聲音。那真是一個超棒的NG鏡頭。
Ed and I could not keep it together. I have a question. We've talked a lot about how on the office there was this real collaboration between the writers and the showrunner and the actors. How much input did you guys have into your lines or changing a line or a storyline? I know that Hair Today Goon Tomorrow was a little bit inspired by Danielle's desire to cut her hair. Yes. I see head shaking. I see head shaking.
艾德和我根本憋不住。我有個問題。我們之前聊過很多次，在《辦公室瘋雲》裡，編劇、節目統籌和演員之間存在著真正的合作關係。你們對自己的台詞、修改台詞或劇情走向有多少發言權呢？我知道《今日頭髮，明日白痴》的靈感部分來自於丹妮爾想要剪頭髮的渴望。對。我看到有人搖頭了。我看到有人搖頭了。
No, it was very top down, no. It was very- When you got to improvise a little bit. I got to, especially towards the later seasons, they kind of let me do my thing. So I could improvise, I would often button scenes, but we weren't really changing our dialogue. Unless something was awful.
不，這完全是由上而下的，沒有。這非常——當你有機會即興發揮一點的時候。我有機會，特別是在後來的幾季，他們基本上讓我自由發揮。所以我可以即興發揮，我經常會為場景做總結（button scenes），但我們其實沒有在改台詞。除非有什麼台詞爛透了。
I had one, I grew up in a military family, and I had one where we do an episode where like you do, a magical cat sends you back to World War II. You know, oh. Like it happens. Yeah, magic cats. Magic cats. And so a lot of the stuff they had me doing
我有過一次，我是在軍人家庭長大，我有一次拍一集節目，劇情是你懂的那種，一隻神奇的貓把你送回了第二次世界大戰。你知道的，噢。這種事居然會發生。對，神奇的貓。神奇的貓。所以他們讓我做的很多事情，
was I'm in a military uniform and being really disrespectful. And I went to our producer and said, I'm not gonna do this. And in all fairness, he went, okay, fine. And they changed it. Yeah. But we as young actors, I won't say kids,
都是我穿著軍服，表現得非常不敬。我去找我們的製作人說：「我才不要演這個。」平心而論，他去了，然後說：「好吧，隨便你。」然後他們就改了。對。但我們作為年輕演員——我不會說我們是小孩——
we weren't really going up. No. In fact, they started taking things from my life more and more, like sort of, you know, sort of being my character was being inspired by writers real life. Yeah. Annoyingly so. And more and more as the show went on and without permission. Yeah. I mean, it's so interesting because of course, as an adult actor, like having input on your character, you know, is like part of the process. But as kids, we never felt we felt like being a good actor would
我們其實不會去提意見。不。事實上，他們越來越多地把我的生活搬進劇裡，就好像，你知道的，我的角色的靈感是來自編劇的真實生活。對。煩人的是，隨著節目繼續播出，這種情況越來越多，而且還沒有經過我的允許。對。我的意思是，這太有趣了，因為當然，作為一個成年演員，對自己的角色有發言權，你知道的，是過程的一部分。但作為小孩子，我們從來不覺得——我們覺得當個好演員就是
be, you know, and probably being told how to say with a line reading. So we were the other thing we talk about on the podcast a lot is that one of the things our executive producer was famous for is we would finish a run through and then we'd all gather for notes and the notes would sometimes be an hour and a half to two hours long of just to each of you like line by line. He'd start on page one and basically like page one, line one have notes about how everything was wrong and how we needed to do it a different way. And it's very clear you guys don't understand
要，你知道的，而且可能還得聽從別人指示該用什麼語調來念台詞。所以我們……我們在Podcast裡經常談到的另一件事是，我們的執行製作人最出名的一點是，我們排練完之後，大家會聚在一起聽意見回饋，有時候回饋會長達一個半小時到兩個小時，針對你們每個人，簡直是逐行逐句地挑毛病。他會從第一頁開始，基本上就是「第一頁，第一行」，指出所有地方都不對，以及我們需要用另一種方式來演。而且很明顯，你們這群傢伙根本不懂
the point of this episode. So let me tell you here's what's... What a fun creative environment. Yeah, it was. But at least we were children. Yeah. So it makes it better. I did hear on your podcast and I love this
這一集的重點。所以讓我來告訴你們，重點是……多麼有趣的創意環境啊。對，確實是。但至少我們當時是小孩子。對。所以這讓人感覺好受一點。我確實聽說你們的Podcast——而且我超愛這個——
that you would find ways to like sneak in a, huh, uh-huh. Yeah, yeah. So now I'm gonna be rooting for that whenever I see it. That is true that we would try to make each other laugh. Yeah, they're in jokes, but they're not in the dialogue. It's the subject. So we're like sending messages to each other with like intonations or physical moves.
你們會找到辦法偷偷塞進一句「哼，嗯哼」。對，對。所以現在每當我看到的時候，我都會為此加油打氣。確實沒錯，我們過去常常試圖把彼此逗笑。對，那是內部笑話，但不在台詞裡。那是主題。所以我們透過語調或肢體動作向彼此傳遞訊息。
Watching it back for the podcast has been so fun to see again and be like, oh my God, I remember this. Yeah. It was also stuff that the writers weren't aware we had. They were truly like inside jokes. It was probably our own little rebellion of like, watch me slip in a joke to my friend that you don't know is a joke.
為了Podcast而回看這些節目真的很有趣，能再次看到並心想：「噢天哪，我記得這個。」對。這也是那些編劇們根本不知道我們在搞甚麼的東西。它們真的是內行笑話。這可能是我們自己小小的叛逆，心想：「看我怎麼神不知鬼不覺地塞一個笑話給我朋友，而你們根本不知道這是個笑話。」
Especially if you'd been told for an hour and a half how you don't get it and you're doing it wrong. I'd want to like sneak in something. Yeah. It wasn't particularly collaborative. It was fun, but it wasn't particularly collaborative. Yeah. Right.
特別是如果你剛被訓了一個半小時，告訴你你根本不懂，而且你演錯了。我會很想偷偷塞點甚麼進去。對。這並不是特別有協作性。這很有趣，但並不是特別有協作性。對。沒錯。
Oh. Sorry. Is our podcast that or the yours? Is our podcast getting there? All right. All right. So I have a pivot here. OK,'t stand her. I can't stand her. I can't stand her. All right, all right, all right. So I have a, I have a pivot here. Okay, so you remember every scene
噢。抱歉。是我們的Podcast這樣，還是你們的？我們的Podcast也是這樣嗎？好啦，好啦。所以我這裡有個轉折。好吧，我受不了她。我受不了她。我受不了她。好啦，好啦，好啦。所以我有個，我這裡有個轉折。好吧，所以你記得每一集
of every episode of The Office. Pretty much, yeah. Well, I thought there was a great crossover story between here today, Goon Tomorrow, and an episode from The Office. Not the one we're watching today, not Surplus, but there is a similar scene. Mm-hmm.
《辦公室瘋雲》裡的每一個場景。差不多吧，對。嗯，我覺得《今日頭髮，明日白痴》和《辦公室瘋雲》的一集之間，有一個很棒的跨界故事。不是我們今天看的這一集，不是《剩餘預算》，但有一個類似的場景。嗯哼。
Mm-hmm. Really? We're meeting a townie. Let's see, a good-looking detective. Good-looking detective. Do you want a hint? Do you want a hint? Yes, give me one, because, yeah.
嗯哼。真的嗎？我們要見一個小鎮居民。讓我想想，一個長相帥氣的偵探。長相帥氣的偵探。你想聽個提示嗎？你想聽個提示嗎？好，給我一個，因為，對。
Small hint. Sofa. Sofa. Sofa. Oh, well. I'm so tickled by this. I'm so kidding. Now, I'm just trying to remember from our episode
小提示。沙發。沙發。沙發。噢，好吧。我被這個逗得好開心。我簡直在開玩笑。現在，我只是在努力回想我們那一集裡
where the sofa. Oh, yeah, OK. There it is, thank you. Yeesh, this is, I pay for that privilege. I only have one weird thing about me. I use the ladies room for number two and I have paid off. And yeah, this is, there's a couch. That's right, okay. That's right, in women's appreciation, the office episode,
沙發在……噢，對，好吧。原來在那裡，謝謝。哎呀，這真是……我可是付了錢才有這特權的。我身上只有一個奇怪的地方。我用女廁上大號，而且我付過錢了。對啦，這裡有一張沙發。沒錯，好吧。沒錯，在女性讚賞日那集《辦公室瘋雲》裡，
the men, first of all, we find out Creed's been using the women's room and they go in there and there's a sofa and they hang out in there. And I thought it was really funny when we watched this episode, you guys were like, there's a sofa. I had the same thought.
男士們——首先，我們發現克雷德一直都在用女廁，然後他們走進去，裡面居然有一張沙發，他們還在那裡閒晃。我覺得當我們看這一集時，你們說「那裡有張沙發」，真的超好笑的。我當時也有同感。
I was like, oh my gosh. And you know what else I thought of? I have not been in very many women's restrooms with sofas. I think at least they have an in they had Nordstrom lounges. And high schools. The girls in our high school had a couch. They had a sofa? We'd go in there to smoke when the boys' room was too full.
我心想：「噢天哪。」你知道我還想到什麼嗎？我沒去過多少有沙發的女廁。我想至少他們有……他們有諾斯楚姆百貨（Nordstrom）的休息室。還有高中。我們高中的女生休息室裡就有一張沙發。她們有一張沙發？當男廁太擠的時候，我們會去那裡抽菸。
Oh. Yeah. I have run across very few sofas. That's Kevin, like, this is the dream. Isn't the dream the girls' locker room? Normally there's girls in there, Kev. Yeah. You're still blown away, dude. I Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Very good.
噢。對。我遇到的有沙發的廁所真的少之又少。那就是凱文的反應：「這簡直是夢想啊。」夢想難道不是女子更衣室嗎？正常來說裡面有女生啊，凱文。對。你還是被震撼到了，老兄。我——對。對。沒錯。非常好。
Still blown away, dude. I know we talked about that you could do this, but when you really can do it, like on the spot, and it's not a bit, it's crazy to me. It's crazy. Way my brain works, yeah. All right, well, guys, this is gonna be so much fun. So much fun, yeah.
依然被震撼到，老兄。我知道我們之前聊過你辦得到這件事，但當你真的能做到，就像這樣當場來一段，而且不是在搞笑時，這對我來說太瘋狂了。太瘋狂了。我大腦運作的方式，對。好吧，各位，這會非常有趣。真的超有趣的，對。
We're excited to be with you. We are gonna take a break, and when we come back, we're going to discuss the surplus. Yay! Yay! All right, everyone. Father's Day is approaching. And guess what? Macy's is your gifting destination. Let Macy's be your guide to gifting for Father's Day. I have been getting all of my holiday gifts at Macy's.com lately. It is fantastic. It's the gift
我們很高興能跟你們在一起。我們要先休息一下，等我們回來後，我們要來討論《剩餘預算》。耶！耶！好了，各位。父親節快到了。你們猜怎麼著？梅西百貨（Macy's）就是你們挑選禮物的首選目的地。讓梅西百貨成為你挑選父親節禮物的嚮導。我最近都在Macy's.com上買我所有的節日禮物。這簡直太棒了。這就是禮物
guide. All right, well, I'm not going to see my dad this Father's Day. They are going on a cruise. How great is that? Fun. And I thought about that amazing pullover that I got him for Christmas that he wears all the time. I got it at Macy's.com. So I went on the Macy's.com Father's Day gifting guide and I put in like vacation wear and I got him the coolest shorts and then kind of like, you know, they're going to the tropics. I got him like a tropical shirt for his cruise. This is stuff my dad will not buy himself. He will not buy like, you know, theme clothing. Oh, I know.
指南。好吧，我今年父親節見不到我爸。他們要去搭郵輪。這有多棒啊？好玩。我想起我聖誕節送他的那件超讚的套頭衫，他一直穿著它。我就是在Macy's.com買的。所以我去了Macy's.com的父親節送禮指南，輸入了像是度假服飾之類的關鍵字，然後我幫他買了最酷的短褲，還有那種，你知道的，因為他們要去熱帶地區，我幫他買了一件熱帶風情的襯衫適合他的郵輪之旅。這些都是我爸自己絕對不會買的東西。他才不會去買那種，你知道的，主題服飾。噢，我懂。
I know. Right? He's all practical. I sent it to him. He loved it. He already got it, you know, because he's going to be gone on Father's Day. So I sent it early and he's thrilled. Well, you know, for Father's Day this year, we're at a volleyball tournament.
我懂。對吧？他超務實的。我寄給了他。他超愛的。他已經收到了，你知道的，因為他父親節不在家。所以我提早寄給他，他超級興奮的。嗯，你知道，今年父親節我們剛好要參加排球錦標賽。
Our son has a volleyball tournament. So that's where we're going to be all day. But we get up super early and Josh is such a coffee guy. So I'm on Macy's.com looking at their gifting guide and they have really great reasonably priced gifts too. And so if you have a coffee lover or you need exercise equipment or I mean, they just have everything in addition to clothes and all the other stuff. I got Lee's gift on Macy's.com, one of his gifts.
我兒子有一場排球錦標賽。所以我們一整天都會待在那裡。但我們得超早起床，而且喬許是個超級咖啡迷。所以我上了Macy's.com瀏覽他們的送禮指南，他們也有非常棒、價格合理的禮物。所以如果你有喜歡喝咖啡的朋友，或者你需要運動器材，我是說，除了衣服和所有其他東西之外，他們應有盡有。我在Macy's.com上買了李的禮物，他的其中一份禮物。
And I don't want to say it, but travel was like my thing in my brain this year. I got him a travel case that holds both sunglasses, eyeglasses, and wristwatches. Oh, that's great. I know. It's super cool. And I think it's something I wouldn't have thought of
我本不想說的，但今年我腦子裡想的「主題」就是旅行。我幫他買了一個旅行收納包，可以同時放太陽眼鏡、老花眼鏡和手錶。噢，那太棒了。我知道。超酷的。而且我覺得如果我沒有看指南，
if I didn't have the guide. Well, I got Josh Colon. He loves, you know, he smells good. He's a good smelling fella. He doesn't go overboard, but I love the way he smells. So I got him Hugo Boss Colon. Macy's has all that kind of stuff. Josh, don't listen, but I think it's going to smell really good on you.
我根本不會想到要買這個。嗯，我幫喬許·科隆買了……他喜歡，你知道的，他聞起來香香的。他是一個味道很好的帥哥。他不會噴過頭，但我超愛他身上的味道。所以我幫他買了雨果博斯（Hugo Boss）古龍水。梅西百貨應有盡有。喬許，別聽這個，但我真的覺得這款味道穿在你身上一定會超香的。
So I'm getting you that for Father's Day. Let Macy's be your guide to gifting this Father's Day. Shop the Father's Day gift guide now at macy's.com slash gift guide. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. Lady, did you see that hilarious Saturday Night Live sketch they did about men's health and mental health where like in order to trick men into taking care of themselves, they made a medical clinic that is like a podcast, like a Dude Bro podcast. Oh my gosh, it's so funny.
所以我今年父親節要送你這個。讓梅西百貨成為你今年父親節送禮的嚮導。現在就到 macy's.com 上的父親節禮品指南選購吧：macy's.com slash gift guide。本節目由 BetterHelp 贊助播出。女士們，你們看到了週末夜現場（Saturday Night Live）那個關於男性健康和心理健康的爆笑短片嗎？片中為了引誘男人們照顧自己的身體，他們開了一家醫療診所，風格聽起來就像個Podcast，就像那種「兄弟幫」Podcast。噢天哪，真的超好笑的。
But it's also because it's kind of true. Men are often reluctant to take the time to dig into their mental health. I've got a stat for you. Six million men in the US suffer from depression every year and it's often undiagnosed. So listen, if you're a man and you're feeling the weight of the world,
但這也是因為它有幾分真實。男人們往往不願意花時間深入關注自己的心理健康。我這裡有一個數據。全美每年有六萬萬（應為六百萬）名男性飽受憂鬱症之苦，而且經常未被確診。所以聽著，如果你是一位男性，正感受到世界的沉重壓力，
we would like to encourage you to talk to someone, a friend, a loved one, a therapist. Maybe you wanna give BetterHelp a try. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Talk it out with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month
我們想鼓勵你去跟別人聊聊，可以是朋友、摯愛，或是治療師。也許你想試試 BetterHelp。身為全球最大的線上心理治療提供者，BetterHelp 能為你提供擁有各種不同專業領域的心理健康專家。透過 BetterHelp 把心事說出來。我們的聽眾在 betterhelp.com 結帳斜線 office ladies 即可享
at betterhelp.com slash office ladies. That's betterhelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies. All right, everybody, we're back, That's betterhelphelp.com slash office ladies. All right, everybody, we're back. And now we're gonna talk about the office episode, the surplus. This was season five, episode nine, written by Jean Stepnitsky and Lee Eisenberg, two of our favorite writers.
第一個月九折優惠。網址是 betterhelp，H-E-L-P 點 com 斜線 office ladies。好了，各位，我們回來了，網址是 betterhelphelp.com 斜線 office ladies。好了，各位，我們回來了。現在我們要來聊聊《辦公室瘋雲》的那一集，即《剩餘預算》。這是第五季第九集，由珍·斯蒂普尼茨基（Gene Stupnitsky）和李·艾森伯格（Lee Eisenberg）編劇，這兩位是我們最愛的編劇。
Writing team. And our beloved director, Paul Feig. Yes, Paul Feig. I think I've worked with Gene and Lee. Yes? I think I did a show, can't remember the name of it, but pretty sure that they wrote on it. Okay.
黃金編劇搭檔。還有我們深愛的導演保羅·費格（Paul Feig）。沒錯，保羅·費格。我想我跟珍和李合作過。是嗎？我想我曾演過一部節目，想不起名字了，但我很確定他們是編劇。好吧。
That is my story. Good story, bro. Hello ladies. Cool story. No. Bad teacher? No, I think it was a pilot. Okay.
這就是我的故事。好故事，兄弟。哈囉，女士們。酷的故事。不。爛老師？不，我覺得那是一部試播集。好吧。
Sometimes with stories. A multicam? Yes. You wanna have detail. No. OK, here's what I will say. I think it happened. I'm pretty sure I worked with Gene and Lee.
有時候關於故事。多機拍攝？對。你想要細節。不。好吧，我要說的是這個。我覺得這事發生過。我很確定我跟珍和李合作過。
They play in several episodes, aren't they? Gene and Leo. That's right. From Vance Refrigeration. So yes, 99.9% sure we have worked together. I vote to cut that part. No, because it's true. Keep it in.
他們在好幾集裡客串過，對吧？珍和李。沒錯。來自凡斯冷凍空調公司（Vance Refrigeration）。所以沒錯，99.9%確定我們合作過。我投贊成票把這段剪掉。不，因為這是真的。保留。
Okay. They're gonna hit you up afterwards and be like, here's the show that we did together with Will. Yeah. We'll look it up. We'll look it up. We'll Google it. Perfect.
好吧。他們事後會聯繫你，然後說：「這是我們和威爾一起合作過的節目。」對。我們會查出來。我們會去查。我們會Google一下。完美。
I'm gonna give you a summary of the episode and here it is. Oscar informs Michael that they have a $4,300 budget surplus and the surplus must be spent that day or it gets returned and taken out of next year's budget. The office is then divided on what to spend it on, new chairs or a new copier. This creates tension between Jim and Pam
我要為大家總結一下這一集，內容是這樣的：奧斯卡通知麥可，他們有4,300美元的預算剩餘，這筆剩餘預算必須在當天花掉，否則就會被收回，並從明年的預算中扣除。於是辦公室為了這筆錢該花在買新椅子還是新影印機上而意見分歧。這在立場對立的
who are on opposing sides. Meanwhile, Andy and Angela visit Shrut Farms to discuss their wedding with Dwight, who tricks Angela into marrying him. I mean, what the heck? Michael then learns a third option for the surplus money, which is return it in exchange for a 15% bonus for himself. Mm-hmm.
吉姆和潘之間製造了緊張氣氛。與此同時，安迪和安琪拉造訪舒特農場，與德懷特討論他們的婚禮，而德懷特卻設局讓安琪拉嫁給了他。我的天啊，搞什麼鬼？麥可隨後得知了這筆剩餘預算的第三種用法，那就是將其退回，以此換取他個人的15%獎金。嗯哼。
Do you know? Do you know? I think, I think you know. Yes. Oh, yes. He has an Oscar surplus. Do you know? Do you think you know?
你知道嗎？你知道嗎？我想，你應該知道。沒錯。噢，沒錯。他有個奧斯卡剩餘預算。你知道嗎？你覺得你知道嗎？
Yeah. I think you know? I think you know. I think you know. What were your overall reactions to this? Because we decided to pick quintessential episodes. And I think the thing I love about this episode so much is that it isn't a later season. And the A story is just a quirky office thing. Yes. That happens all the time.
對。你覺得你知道？我覺得你知道。我覺得你知道。你們對這一集的整體反應是什麼？因為我們決定挑選最具代表性的集數。而我覺得我之所以這麼愛這一集，是因為它不是後期的集數。而且主線劇情只是一件古怪的辦公室瑣事。沒錯。
All the time in offices. Yeah, where like the hot goss that's going around is about something as mundane as chairs versus copier. And the dynamics of- Spins everybody out of control. No one's focusing, no one's, by the way, no work is getting done in that office ever. The manure being in the kitchen, in fruit farms. And also like no one is clocking the odor.
辦公室裡經常發生這種事。對，像是大家在八卦的熱門話題竟然是買椅子還是買影印機這種芝麻小事。而這種動態——把每個人都搞瘋了。沒人專心，沒人——順便一提，那間辦公室裡從來沒有人在工作。糞便居然出現在舒特農場的廚房裡。而且居然沒有人注意到那個味道。
Like people talking. And it's a big pile of shit like right next to the table. It just really made me laugh out loud. Yeah, you know what makes me laugh every time I watch this episode is when Mike Shur is most hits Ed, his head in the head. With the ball. In the background. Yes. Yeah. It cracks me up every time because I really think that Ed wasn't quite expecting it.
就像大家在聊天。結果桌子旁邊居然有一大堆狗屎。這真的把我逗得哈哈大笑。對，你知道每次我看這一集時，是什麼讓我笑出來嗎？就是麥可·舒爾（Mike Schur）用球狠狠砸了艾德的頭。在背景裡。對。沒錯。每次都把我逗笑，因為我覺得艾德當時真的沒料到這一出。
So every time he's like, hey. It does look like he turns around really confrontational. Like, yeah. What just happened there? Which is it's so funny. I'm somewhere in between Ryder and Will with my viewing of The Office. I'm pretty sure I have seen most seasons every episode at some point. I do not have a fraction of Will's photographic memory for them. Who does?
所以每次他都一副「嘿」的反應。他看起來真的轉過身去，一副要找人算帳的樣子。就像是，對。剛剛發生了什麼事？這真的太好笑了。我對《辦公室瘋雲》的喜愛程度大概介於萊德和威爾之間。我很確定我曾在某個時候看過大部分季節的每一集。我可沒有威爾那種過目不忘的記憶力。誰有啊？
And wait, Ryder, had you seen this episode? No, I don't think so. Yeah, no. But it felt like a quintessential office episode. That's what I remembered the show being, like sort of, you know, like you're saying, detailed, like meaningless conflict that just blows up and gets to show people's behavior.
等等，萊德，你看過這集嗎？沒有，我不覺得我有看過。對，沒有。但這感覺就是一集極具代表性的《辦公室瘋雲》。這就是我記憶中這部節目的樣子，就像——你知道的，就像你們說的，細節滿滿，毫無意義的衝突卻無限放大，進而展現出人們的行為舉止。
I thought it was hysterical. I mean, it's brilliant. It's so funny. And like the show's ability to make awful actions incredibly like, well, it's just unparalleled. You know, I feel like a lot of what your show brought was like, you know, the beginning of like cringe comedy or like, but cringe comedy usually is mean
我覺得這集簡直太爆笑了。我是說，這太精采了。真的超好笑的。而且這部影集能把糟糕的行為變得如此……嗯，簡直是無與倫比。你知道，我覺得你們節目帶來的很多東西，就像是尷尬喜劇（cringe comedy）的開端，但尷尬喜劇通常都很刻薄，
or like people are kind of awful and you're like, oh my God, I can't believe this person said that. Whereas like every time Michael opens up his mouth, it's the funniest thing ever. And you're like, I like that guy. Yeah. He's, I mean, you don't want to, and everybody, you know, Dwight even who is sort of more on the meaner side,
或者人們表現得很討厭，你會想：「噢天哪，我真不敢相信這人居然說得出這種話。」然而，每當麥可開口說話，那絕對是史上最好笑的事。你會想：「我滿喜歡這傢伙的。」對。他——我是說，你不會想去——而且每個人，你知道的，甚至是稍微偏向刻薄那一掛的德懷特，
you still love him. Like everybody, and the show is just so brilliant that it manages to pull that off and still have very comedic, like I was laughing out loud and I realized I have not laughed out loud, even at comedy these days. I feel like comedy these days, you're sort of like, you know, or like whatever.
你還是會很愛他。就像每個人一樣，這部影集就是這麼厲害，它能完美駕馭這種風格，同時還能兼具強烈的喜劇效果——我當時一邊看一邊哈哈大笑，然後我意識到自己已經很久沒有大笑過了，即便是現在的喜劇節目也一樣。我覺得現在的喜劇節目，你大概只會覺得「哼」，或者之類的。
You guys managed while being incredibly realistic with the performances and understated, still big laughs. Laugh out loud beats. And so I just think it's such an accomplishment and like a legendary show for that. Jenna, you saying, no, don't take it away when he's shaking his butt in the show. That was my favorite moments, yes.
你們在保持表演極具真實感且低調的同時，依然能制造出巨大的笑點。讓人捧腹大笑的節奏。所以我認為這真是一個了不起的成就，也是一部傳奇性的影集。珍，你說「不，當他在節目裡扭屁股時，別把這段剪掉」。那是我最喜歡的時刻之一，沒錯。
You're so sweet. It was the perfect amount of all of us knowing that you are faking it, but also easily plays like you mean it in the moment. Right, when she starts to have to dance with him. He's sort of thinking, I see you like half-hearted, and I'm like, I'm gonna act, and I'm crazy perfect. Cause you see all of it, like, I guess I'm gonna dance now,
你太可愛了。這完美拿捏了所有人都知道你在假裝，但同時又演得好像當下你是真心實意的那種感覺。對，當她開始不得不跟他跳舞時。他心裡大概在想：「我看你也是心不甘情願的嘛。」然後我就想：「我要開始演了，我簡直瘋狂完美。」因為你把所有細節都表現出來了，像是「好吧，我想我現在得跳舞了，
no, we're stopping good. Okay, it's like all there in that moment. It's so funny. Also you fluffing your hair with the red lip. All right, know what I gotta do here. It's on, it is so on. This episode, I'm so glad you guys picked this one. It's one of my favorites.
不，我們停下來，很好。」好了，一切都在那個瞬間完美呈現。這太好笑了。還有你用塗著紅唇的嘴唇撥弄頭髮的樣子。好了，我知道我現在該怎麼做了。開始了，這真的太誇張了。這一集，我太高興你們選了這一集。這是我最愛的集數之一。
It has, in my opinion, the most underrated joke of any office episode. And I find it to be one of the funniest things ever said on the entire show, and it's that fast. Which one is it? It is the very beginning when Oscar is explaining to Michael about the lemonade stand and he just says in the next summer, Michael just goes, I'll be six.
依我看，它擁有《辦公室瘋雲》所有集數中最被低估的一個笑話。我覺得這是整部影集裡講過最好笑的事情之一，而且節奏超快。是哪一個？就是一開始奧斯卡在向麥可解釋檸檬水攤的時候，他隨口說了句「明年夏天」，然後麥可直接回了一句：「我那時就六歲了。」
That's like he's so excited. He thinks he's got the point of the whole thing. It's like now I know the math. Because he just says, I'll be six. Genius on so many levels. I remember the first time I see it, just keep reminding like, it's the perfect joke. It is the perfect joke. So it's just, oh, I just explained to me like I'm eight
就好像他超级兴奋。他觉得自己抓住了整件事的精髓。这就好比，我现在懂数学了。因为他刚说，我六岁。在很多层面上都是天才。我还记得我第一次看的时候，脑子里一直闪现，这真是完美的笑话。这确实是完美的笑话。所以就是，哦，快用我八岁智商的水平解释给我听
and then he does, and I'll be six. Oh gosh, it is so well done. Now this is like, we talked about the Boy Meets World episode, we talked about this episode is so well balanced between the A story and the B story. It's so funny how you find heart in the office because the scene where Angela finally says to Dwight, I made a mistake.
然后他真的这么做了，我会六岁。哦天哪，真的太精彩了。现在这就好像，我们之前讨论过《男孩世界》的那集，我们谈到这一集在A故事和B故事之间的平衡做得太好了。你在办公室里发现温情的那一刻是多么有趣，因为安吉拉终于对德怀特说，我犯了一个错误。
Yeah. You've been waiting for this. I'm taking a mistake. I'm supposed to be with you. Yeah. It's a big deal. Dwight, of course, says, well, yeah, well, I know. And that's why I just tricked you into marrying me.
是的。你一直在等这一刻。我犯了个错误。我本来就该跟你在一起。是的。这可是件大事。德怀特当然会说，嗯，对啊，我知道。这就是为什么我设局诱骗你跟我结婚。
And you should have learned German when I told you to. Exactly. I've been telling you to take it for years. It is just, that's one of the things I love about your show is that our show, you know you're gonna get heart because the music swells. And we're telling you, you're going to get heart. Your show, you find it in beats
而且我叫你学德语的时候你早就该学了。一点没错。我跟你说过好几年了，让你去学。这就是我热爱你们剧的原因之一，在我们剧里，你知道一定会有温情，因为音乐会渐渐高潮。而且我们在提醒你，温情要来了。而你们的剧，你能在那些
that you don't think are gonna exist. And it's Pam being drunk and falling off the chair at Chili's and then Jim picking her up and then Tiny Dancer slowly starting to play in the background. It's all just, it's all beautiful. So yeah, but this episode though, and then of course the ending, which is magical, the magical tag.
你根本意想不到的节奏中发现温情。比如帕姆喝醉了，在奇利餐厅从椅子上摔下来，然后吉姆扶她起来，接着《微小舞者》的音乐开始在背景中缓缓响起。这一切都，这一切都太美妙了。所以，是的，不过这一集，然后当然还有那个结局，简直太神奇了，那个神奇的尾声。
By the way, I didn't see that coming when he's wearing the fur coat. I thought, oh, I love that we're just going to see that he bought a fur coat. And I, the blood was just, how did they talk? Even just the fact that he bought a fur coat. And the blood was just how did they talk? Even just the fact that he had the fur coat. But also, I was blown away by the writing in that because it starts when you are asking him about his suit and you're using the suit. And that's where he throws out how much the suit costs. And so I thought that was it.
顺便说一句，他穿着皮大衣出场时我完全没料到。我还以为，哦，太棒了，我们只是会看到他买了一件皮大衣。然后那些血迹只是……他们是怎么聊的？甚至只是他有一件皮大衣这件事。然后那些血迹只是……他们是怎么聊的？甚至只是他买了一件皮大衣这件事。而且，我被里面的编剧惊艳到了，因为它是从你问他关于西装的事开始的，你用到了那套西装。正是在那里，他脱口而出这套西装花了多少钱。所以当时我以为这就是全部了。
But then he brings up the Burlington Coat Factory because it makes him wanting that $600 so much better. Because if you hadn't planted the seed that he is trying to save money by getting good suits, $5, but it starts as just this you flattering him joke, then it builds to a coat at the end and all you needed to see, like I mean, the tag could have just been him like doing the interview in the coat and I was already dying.
但接着他提到了伯灵顿外套工厂，因为这让渴望得到那600美元的情节变得好笑得多。因为如果你没有提前铺垫他在通过买好西装来省钱，哪怕只要5美元，但它最初只是一个拍他马屁的笑话，然后到了结尾变成了一件大衣，而你只需要看到的画面——我是说，尾声本可以只是他在大衣里做采访，而我已经快笑死了。
That's what I thought. I thought, wow, of mean, the tag could have just been him, like, doing the interview in the code, and I was already dying. That's what I'm saying, that's what I thought. I thought, wow, of course, that was such a payoff, but then they even found the topper to it. Yes, yeah. One of the things I never get tired of, even in our rewatch, is Steve as Michael, when he's about to curse and they cut him off. Oh, yes.
我也是这么想的。我还以为，哇，我的意思是，尾声本可以只是他在大衣里做采访，而我已经快笑死了。我是说，我也是这么想的。我还以为，哇，当然，那样的回报已经够丰厚了，但他们居然还找到了更绝的包袱。是的，没错。我百看不厌的情节之一，哪怕在我们重温时也是如此，就是史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔，当他正要爆粗口却被打断的时候。哦，是的。
He's like, mother, it's a curse. Always so funny. As you guys call his bluff on getting the chairs, I just loved it so much. I've always wanted to know, how much did the script stay the same from when you first got it to when you actually shot? Like how much are you ad-libbing
他说，妈的，这可是个脏话。总是那么搞笑。当你们几个叫板让他把椅子拿出来时，我真的太喜欢了。我一直很想知道，从你们拿到剧本到真正开拍，剧本保留了多少？你们有多少是即兴发挥
and just going with on the moment, and how much was actually on the page? Well, do you mean sort of from our table read to what we shot? Table read draft to shooting draft? Yes. Or shooting draft to what you see on air? Both.
全凭当时的感觉，又有多少是真正写在纸上的？好吧，你是说从我们围读到开拍之间吗？从围读稿到拍摄稿？是的。还是从拍摄稿到你们在电视上看到的？两者都有。
Yeah, both. I would say there would be some pretty big changes between the table read draft and the shooting draft. But then the shooting draft to what you see on screen, a lot less than you would think. Whoever wrote the episode would also be on set with the director producing their episode. And they would be throwing out extra lines and ideas.
对，两者都有。我想说，围读稿和拍摄稿之间会有相当大的改动。但从拍摄稿到你在屏幕上看到的，比你想象的要少得多。写这一集的编剧也会和导演一起在片场监制他们的那一集。他们会随时抛出额外的台词和想法。
So a lot of times it wasn't an improv, but it was an alternate that the writers gave you. Likewise, though, you could go to the writers. We had the permission to go to the writers and it was a real creative collaboration. So you could go up and say, hey, I have a really great button for the scene and accounting. Will you let me know once we've got it the way you want it the way the director wants it and then can I do like my pass? Oh, that's great. Yeah. And you, we were smart enough that you didn't improvise within the scene. You know, if you did tops in the bottom, that way they can edit around, you don't mess with the storyline.
所以很多时候并不是即兴发挥，而是编剧给你的备选台词。同样地，你也可以去找编剧。我们有权限去找编剧，这真的是一种很有创造力的合作。所以你可以走过去说，嘿，我在记账部门的那场戏里有一个特别棒的妙语。等你们拍到导演和你们想要的效果之后，能让我试一下我自己的版本吗？哦，那太棒了。对。而且，我们都很聪明，不会在场景内部随意即兴发挥。你知道，如果你加了开头和结尾，这样他们就可以在剪辑时避开，而不会把剧情搞砸。
And I think a lot of little moments like that do make it in. But it was truly just a great scripted show. But I think if you went to the script and you looked at that Michael talking head that is the tag, it would be word for word. It would, OK. Like, very often. Also, they would write in ellipses. They would write in pauses.
我觉得很多这样的小细节确实保留了下来。但它真的只是一部制作精良的剧本剧。不过我想如果你去看剧本，找到那个作为尾声的迈克尔面对镜头的访谈，它一定是逐字逐句的。绝对是，好吧。就像，非常经常这样。而且，他们会在里面写出省略号。他们会写出停顿。
They would write in Pam glances to camera. So like, all of that that just like seems like it's just happening, it was choreographed. Wow. And then also the idea that the camera would get to you in the middle of what you're saying, instead of landing on you perfectly. We were going to say it or that the joke was over there.
他们会写出帕姆瞥向镜头的动作。所以，所有这些看起来像是即兴发生的事情，其实都是精心编排过的。哇。而且，镜头会移动到你正在说话的正中间，而不是完美地定格在你身上。我们本来要说的，或者笑点在那边。
Part of the comedy came from getting to it late. So they would actually put that in the script, like whip hand to? Yeah, whip to Jim. Yeah, Jim looks to camera. Yeah, Jim's size. Okay, so those looks to camera were always looks to camera or did they get a shorthand eventually in the script
喜剧的效果有一部分来自于晚了一步切到镜头。所以他们真的会把这个写进剧本里，比如“迅速切到”？是的，“切到吉姆”。对，吉姆看向镜头。对，吉姆叹气。好吧，所以那些看向镜头永远都是看向镜头，还是说剧本里最终形成了一种速记符号？
or they were just like, give us the look? Sometimes you could tag the camera, like if you wanted, but they didn't want everyone looking down the barrel of the camera all the time. So, you know, like I'm not sure if it said in the camera, like, if you wanted, but they didn't want everyone looking down the barrel of the camera all the time. So, you know, like, I'm not sure if it said in the script, like, that I'm checking in with camera because I'm embarrassed that I'm, what I'm doing to Michael. Like, some of those just ended up becoming second nature,
或者他们只是说，给我们一个眼神？有时你可以给镜头一个眼神，如果你愿意的话，但他们并不希望每个人一直盯着镜头的镜头筒。所以，你知道，就像我不确定剧本里是不是写了，比如，如果我想的话，但他们并不希望每个人一直盯着镜头的镜头筒。所以，你知道，就像我不确定剧本里是不是写了，比如我在和镜头眼神交流，因为我对我的所作所为、我对迈克尔做的事感到尴尬。比如，其中一些最后就成了自然而然的本能反应，
like, you know, like, to kind of give the camera like, oh my God, I'm so, so sorry. We had A camera catching the main scene and then B camera was always roving the background. So you had to be on from the minute you were at your desk. Oh, I love that so much. And you had to be in character. It's very actory.
就像，你知道的，给镜头一个“天呐，我太、太抱歉了”的表情。我们有A摄像机捕捉主场景，然后B摄像机总是在背景中游走。所以你从坐在办公桌前的第一分钟起就必须进入状态。哦，我太喜欢这个了。而且你必须保持角色状态。这非常具有演员素养。
You have to be in character. And our B camera operator, Matt Stone, would often come up to us in the background and say, I can see your screen, log out of your email. Or he would say something like, I just saw that you did an eye roll after Pam says that line. You're in the deep background, but it was great and I caught it.
你必须保持在角色里。我们的B摄像机操作员马特·斯通经常会在背景中走到我们面前说，我能看到你的屏幕，退出你的邮箱。或者他会说这样的话，我刚看到帕姆说完那句台词后你翻了个白眼。你在最深处的背景里，但太棒了，被我捕捉到了。
So if you want to do it again, I caught it. So that was just us staying in character. But that's how the crew was so much part of the creative process. Cause they were finding moments that weren't necessarily on the page, right, that helped tell out, you know, fill out the whole story. One of the things that we noticed about our show is that as it progressed, they started
所以如果你想再做一次，我刚刚拍到了。所以这只是我们保持角色状态的一种方式。但这就是为什么剧组能如此大地参与到创作过程中。因为他们会发现一些未必写在纸上的时刻，对吧，这些时刻有助于展开、你知道的，丰富整个故事。我们注意到我们剧的一个特点是，随着剧情的发展，他们开始
to notice which characters really worked with other characters. So airs started to form. Did you start to notice that on your set as well? Like all of a sudden, because, you know, as the show progresses for a while, all of a sudden, you know, Pam and Angela start to have kind of an interesting dynamic. Was that something you think that was planned at the beginning, or was it they were just looking at what worked and then started to write
注意到哪些角色和哪些角色在一起时效果特别好。于是各种组合开始形成。你们在自己的片场也开始注意到这一点了吗？比如突然之间，因为，你知道，随着剧集发展了一段时间，突然之间，你知道，帕姆和安吉拉开始产生了一种有趣的化学反应。你觉得这是从一开始就计划好的，还是他们只是观察什么效果好，然后开始针对
to the relationships they saw? Well, our writers told us that something they would do sometimes is they would get a writing assignment where they would just take a random pairing of actors, and they'd have to pitch storylines for them. Oh, that's so cool. For characters.
他们看到的角色关系来进行创作？好吧，我们的编剧告诉我们，他们有时会做的一件事是，他们会接到一个写作任务，随机挑选两个演员的组合，然后必须为他们构思故事线。哦，太酷了。为角色构思。
Genius. And there's an episode, I can't remember what the name of it is, where they all go out in pairs on sales calls. Uh-huh, oh yes, yeah. Oh, yes, so it's Jonathan and Karen. You're the mother-daughter team, you're the young firefighters.
真是天才。有一集，我记不清叫什么名字了，他们所有人都成双成对地出去打销售电话。嗯哼，哦对，没错。哦，是的，那是乔纳森和凯伦。你们是母女档，你们是年轻的消防员。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Right, and that was an episode that came out of that, they would call it the the unusual pairings. Oh, no, that was the salesman, the return. Yes. Yes. The return. Yes. I really wish we had to. I could have helped out. Yes. Can you just come sit in on a. I would be happy to. That's what it starts with.
对，对，对。没错，那一集就是这么诞生的，他们管这叫不寻常的组合。哦，不，那是销售员的回归。是的。没错。回归。是的。我真的很希望我们也有。我本可以去帮忙的。是的。你能去旁听一下吗？我非常乐意。就是从这开始的。
Cassie, our producer, we're like Cassie, go go. I wait. What episode was that? Yeah. Dwight is bringing has to bring the late taxes back to New York. He misses the entire time for Angela. For Noelle. And yes, exactly. That's when your hair, the back of your hair was very-
卡西，我们的制片人，我们当时就说卡西，快去快去。等等。那是哪一集？对。德怀特把迟交的税表送回纽约。他错过了安吉拉的全部时间。诺埃尔的。还有，没错。那就是你的发型，你脑后的发型非常——
It's like a pinwheel. Yeah, the pinwheel all the way around. Very dramatic, the way they did the back of your hair in that episode. One of my favorite, like completely undiscussed jokes is when Michael is pouring sugar into a guy's- Exactly! Is that in the script?
就像一个风车。对，四周都是风车造型。太戏剧化了，他们在那一集里把你脑后的发型弄成那样。我最喜欢的、完全没怎么被讨论过的笑话之一，就是迈克尔把糖倒进某人的——没错！那是剧本里的吗？
Will something like that always be in the script? Yes, that is in the script. That's in the show Bible for Michael Scott that he adds sugar to his diet so bad. That's what I was gonna say. Oh my God, it's like perfect. Yes, so what was great I loved about our show is like let's say that's established one time
像这样的事情总是会写进剧本里吗？是的，那在剧本里。那是迈克尔·斯科特的官方设定集里的一部分，他往饮食里加糖加得离谱。我正要这么说呢。天呐，简直绝了。是的，所以最棒的是我喜欢我们剧的一点是，假设这个设定在早期某季建立了一次
in an early season, that it keeps finding its moment back into the show. Yeah, yeah. We got one small glimpse of it because I have all the DVDs and when you got to the dinner party, which is arguably one of the greatest, they gave you the script. The script came with the DVD. Oh, no way. So you got, it was the size of sides, but you got actually the script.
它会不断在剧里找到回归的时刻。对，对。我们只瞥见了小小的一幕，因为我有所有的DVD，当你看到晚宴那一集时，可以说是有史以来最棒的一集之一，他们把剧本也给你了。剧本是跟着DVD一起送的。哦，真的假的？所以你拿到的，虽然尺寸像是台词页，但实际上是完整的剧本。
And I was, that's why I wanted to ask, because some of the stuff was right on and other stuff it was like, okay, they said, Andy harmonizes with the song, but then he kind of goes off and does his own thing. So I was just curious how much you got to play as you were doing it because it was, man, it was so good. We did get to play a lot. We did.
我就是想问这个，因为有些内容完全对得上，而有些内容感觉就像是，好吧，他们写着，安迪跟着歌声和声，但他后来有点跑偏了，自己玩自己的。所以我很好奇当你们在拍的时候，有多少发挥的空间，因为，天呐，真的太棒了。我们确实有很多发挥空间。真的。
Most of the time, like, I feel like what you ended up seeing on screen was, it was mostly scripted. Yeah. Gotcha. But it was mostly scripted. Yeah. Gotcha. It was a very playful collaborative set. It must have been so fun. It was so fun. You talked about alternate takes that you would use. You have one of my favorites, which they didn't put in, which you say, I used to get a runner's high,
大多数时候，就像，我觉得你最终在屏幕上看到的，基本上都是按照剧本演的。对。明白了。但基本上都是按照剧本演的。对。明白了。这是一个非常具有玩乐性质、合作无间的片场。一定超级有趣。真的超级有趣。你刚才提到你们会使用备选镜头。你有一个我最喜欢的，但他们没剪进去的镜头，你当时说，我以前经常享受奔跑者的亢奋，
which is why now I lift. And which didn't make it into the show, which I thought should have. They were called our candy bag alts, and our writers would write, you know, so you would have one talking head, they might write 10 extras. Wow.
这就是为什么我后来开始举重。这句台词没能进入正片，我觉得应该放进去的。它们被称为我们的“糖果袋”备选，我们的编剧会写，你知道的，所以你拍一个访谈镜头，他们可能会写10个额外的版本。哇。
You would get handed those pages as you sat down, you would learn the one in the script, they would hand them to you right as you started your talking heads and you would get the scripted one. Then you'd kind of look down and do the rest. And a lot of times in talking heads, that's where you can play a little bit too. Yeah. And Greg Daniels, we asked him, like, why did you call him the candy bag? Yeah, he named him the candy bag. Yeah, so you guys here are the candy bag.
当你坐下来的时候，你会拿到那些纸，你会背熟剧本里的那一句，而在你刚开始做访谈时他们会把备选递给你，你会拿到写在剧本里的那句。然后你会低头看一眼，把剩下的演完。很多时候在访谈镜头里，这也是你可以稍微即兴发挥的地方。对。而且格雷格·丹尼尔斯，我们问过他，为什么管它叫“糖果袋”？对，他给它取名叫“糖果袋”。对，所以你们听到的这就是“糖果袋”。
And he said, well, I knew it was a lot of extra stuff and I didn't want you guys to be mad, so I thought I'd name it something fun. It's a candy bag. So smart. It's a bag of candy. Yeah. It's like if I called him the alts.
他说，嗯，我知道这里面有很多额外的东西，我不想让你们烦心，所以我想给它起个有趣的名字。这就叫糖果袋。太聪明了。这就是一袋糖果。对。就像我管它叫备选一样。
Yeah, that would be amazing. Here's your oatmeal alts. I have 10 Alts. I have 10 Alts. Whether it's a family member, friend or furry companion joining your summer road trip, enjoy the peace of mind that comes with Volvo's legendary safety. During Volvo Discover Days, enjoy limited time savings as you make plans to cruise through Muscogee or down Toronto's bustling streets. From now until June 30th, lease a 2025 Volvo XC60 from 1.74% and save up to $4,000. Condition
对，那太棒了。这是你的燕麦片备选。我有10个备选。我有10个备选。无论是家人、朋友还是毛茸茸的同伴加入您的夏日公路旅行，都能享受沃尔沃传奇安全带来的安心。在沃尔沃探索日期间，当您计划穿梭于马斯科基或多伦多繁华的街道时，即可享受限时优惠。即日起至6月30日，租赁2025款沃尔沃XC60，利率低至1.74%，最高可省4000美元。条件
supply. Visit your GTA Volvo retailer or go to volvocars.ca for full details. Visit your GTA Volvo retailer or go to volvocars.ca for full details. So something I want to ask you guys, people always ask us, why do you think the office is so relatable? And I don't think that the answer is because everyone's worked in an office, because clearly not everyone has worked in an office. But I did work in an office and so did Angela. And I'm curious, since you guys grew up doing television, you were actors by the time you were adults. Did you ever work in an office? I've never had a real job.
适用。请访问您的GTA沃尔沃零售商或访问volvocars.ca了解完整详情。请访问您的GTA沃尔沃零售商或访问volvocars.ca了解完整详情。所以我想问你们一个问题，人们总是问我们，你们觉得为什么《办公室》能引起这么大的共鸣？我不认为答案是因为每个人都在办公室工作过，因为显然不是每个人都在办公室工作过。但我确实在办公室工作过，安吉拉也是。我很想知道，既然你们俩从小就在电视圈长大，成年时已经是演员了。你们有没有在办公室工作过？我从来没有过正经工作。
Have any of you guys? I've never had a real job in my life. I worked in customer service. Okay. For Bloomingdale's. You have a very good customer service voice. Thank you. Yes, I appreciate that. Yeah, I worked in customer service. I really only got the job because I'm a good gift wrapper. Oh! Was that part of it? It was during a holiday for gift wrapping. So I actually just wanted to wrap presents. And they were like, well, it's a customer service job.
你们有谁过吗？我这辈子从来没有过正经工作。我在客服部门工作过。好吧。为布鲁明代尔百货。你有一个非常好的客服嗓音。谢谢。是的，我很感激。对，我在客服工作过。我得到这份工作其实只是因为我擅长包礼物。哦！这也是其中的一部分？那是节假日期间的礼品包装工作。所以我其实只是想包礼物。而他们的反应是，好吧，这是个客服工作。
And it was like, could I just be the person in customer service who wraps the presents? And the truth was, I did get to wrap most of the presents, but I also had to like be there to help people with their credit card bill and deal with other issues. You know, the Bloomingdale sale where you get a $25 gift card for every $200 you spend. I had to help people with that stuff.
然后我说，我能不能就当那个在客服部门专门包礼物的人？事实是，我确实包了大部分礼物，但我也必须坐在那里帮处理信用卡账单以及处理其他问题。你知道布鲁明代尔的促销活动吗，消费满200美元就送25美元礼品卡。我得帮人们处理那些事情。
I had that real job. Okay, so there's a very famous episode where Pam says that if you need more than three pieces of tape to wrap a present, you're doing it wrong. How many pieces of tape do you use? And I disagree with Pam as Angela Kinsey because I tape the crap out of my gifts. Like, good luck opening them. So I use double-sided tape. Oh, fancy.
我有过那种正经工作。好吧，所以有一个非常著名的桥段，帕姆说如果你包装礼物需要用到三截以上的胶带，那你就是做错了。你包装礼物用几截胶带？作为安吉拉·金西，我跟帕姆意见不一致，因为我在礼物上贴了超级多的胶带。祝他们好运，看他们怎么拆开。所以我用双面胶。哦，真讲究。
Next level. So you need one to cover the back and at least two to do the perfect triangle folds on each end. Okay. So is there a way to do it with only folds on each end. Okay. So is there a way to do it with only three pieces of tape? Yes. Do you get the most bang for your buck presentation wise? No.
更上一层楼。所以你需要一截盖住背面，至少两截在两头做出完美的三角形折角。好吧。那么有没有办法只用两头的折角就能搞定呢？好吧。那么有没有办法只用三截胶带搞定？可以。这样做在视觉呈现上性价比最高吗？不是。
So can I do it? Yes. Do I do it? No. By the way, the next couple of lines after three pieces of tape are Roy then says, well, can I just use the comics from the newspaper? And you say, yeah, your mother would love that. Oh my gosh, that is nuts.
所以我会不会这样做？会。我会不会这么做？不会。顺便说一句，在说到三截胶带之后的几句台词，罗伊接着说，那我能不能直接用报纸上的漫画？然后你说，对，你妈一定会喜欢那个。天呐，太疯狂了。
Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. You know, every holiday season, people send that to me. And I use way more than three pieces a day. I wrap a gift. And every time I give a gift to someone, I feel like they're judging me. No, no, it's just because you care more about the aesthetics.
天呐。天呐。你知道，每个假期季节，人们都会把那个发给我。而我用的胶带远不止三截。我包装一个礼物。每次我送别人礼物，我都觉得他们在评判我。不，不，那只是因为你更在乎美观度。
OK. thank you. So now you guys have never worked in an office. No. And have you ever had jobs other than actor or producer? I mean, not entertainment, yeah, not entertainment, just teaching. I teach, but that's it. You teach history.
好吧，谢谢。所以你们俩从来没有在办公室工作过。没有。除了演员或制片人，你们还做过其他工作吗？我是说，不是娱乐圈的，对，不是娱乐圈的，就是教书。我教书，但仅此而已。你教历史。
I worked one day in a motorcycle shop when I was 13. Were you on hiatus from the show or was this before the show? It was before the show. I was on Nickelodeon at the time. OK. But it was my dad. It was his client and I just bought a motorcycle and I wanted to learn more about them. So I thought this was my in. I worked one day and then that was it.
我13岁时在一家摩托车行工作过一天。你是从剧组暂时停工期间去的，还是在这部剧之前？在这部剧之前。我当时在尼克频道工作。好吧。但那是我的爸爸。那是他的客户，我刚买了一辆摩托车，想更多地了解它们。所以我以为这是我的内部通道。我工作了一天，然后就结束了。
Because you quit or you got fired? Neither. It was just I think he thought, OK, I'm going to let him come in here one day. Other than a child actor, I didn't even know it was legal to work before at least the age of 15. I don't think it was, but most of the shit I did wasn't legal by the time I did it. I know, that's true. That's true. He also started smoking at 11, so. I was a heavy smoker by 11. Oh my God. He's got a weird life.
因为你辞职了还是被解雇了？都不是。只是我觉得他当时想，好吧，我让他进来待一天。除了童星，我甚至不知道15岁以前工作是否合法。我想是不合法的，但我干过的破事里，等我做的时候大部分也都不合法。我知道，确实如此。确实如此。他11岁就开始抽烟了，所以。我11岁就是个老烟枪了。天呐。他过着离奇的生活。
A wonderful, beautiful, weird life. I just picture you smoking on the subway going into New York for my job. I was. Yeah, that was me. Yeah, 11 to 37. 35. Actually, May 27. Coming up, we're going into New York for my job. Yeah, I was. Yeah, that was me. Yeah, 11 to 37, 35. Actually, May 27th. Coming up. Hey, anniversary.
精彩、美丽而离奇的生活。我脑海里浮现出你抽着烟坐地铁去纽约上班的画面。我确实是。没错，那个人就是我。对，从11岁到37岁。35岁。其实是5月27日。接下来的节目，我们要去纽约上班。是的，我就是这样。没错，那个人就是我。对，从11岁到37、35岁。其实是5月27日。接下来的节目。嘿，纪念日。
It will be my 11 year anniversary without a cigarette. That's great. Thank you very much. Congratulations. I miss it all the time. I don't actually. But no, yeah, so I know I never had a job. Well, you know, this gets a little bit to my point,
这将是我戒烟11周年的纪念日。那太棒了。非常感谢。恭喜你。我无时无刻不在想念它。其实并没有。不过，没有，对，所以我知道我从来没有真正打过工。好吧，你知道，这有点触及我的观点了，
which is that I feel like the reason why the office works is because you don't have to work in an office to know a Dwight. No, no. Or to have met your Michael. No, it's all just human behavior. It's so good. It's so relatable.
那就是我觉得《办公室》之所以成功，是因为你不需要在办公室工作过也知道什么是德怀特。不，不需要。或者不需要遇到过你的迈克尔。不，这全都是人类的行为模式。太棒了。太有共鸣了。
And the performances are just amazing. Yeah. And I feel like you guys changed television, because you just brought everything down a notch. Still, like I said, still managing to pull off big laughs, giant set pieces. But man, it's just so nice to see people behaving like people. You know, and like when we go back and watch our show,
而且演员们的表演简直绝了。对。我觉得你们改变了电视界，因为你们把一切都降了一个八度。就像我说的，依然能够制造出巨大的笑声、震撼的大场面。但是天呐，看到人们像真正的人类一样行事，感觉太美妙了。你知道，就像我们回头看我们的剧时，
as much as I'm able to say like, it was good. Like it was, you know, it's a sitcom. It's a very stylized form of rhythm and acting. And it has its benefits. Realism though, like, you know, I mean, often we would have moments of realism, but you know, the jokes were like, da-da-da-da-da, you know, you're just hitting it.
尽管我能够说，它挺好的。就像它，你知道的，是一部情景喜剧。这是一种高度风格化的节奏和表演形式。它有它的好处。不过现实主义，你知道，我的意思是，通常我们会有现实主义的时刻，但你知道，笑话的节奏是，哒-哒-哒-哒-哒，你知道的，你只是在赶节奏。
And you guys didn't have any of that, still had a musicality, still had a rhythm, but it was part of the camera. It's really remarkable and yeah. But what you were doing is really difficult, and you do it so well on the show, and I couldn't do it. In my early acting struggles and trying to land a role, I was going out for three camera because
而你们完全没有那种感觉，依然有音乐感，依然有节奏，但它是融入镜头之中的。这真的很了不起，是的。但你们在做的事情其实非常困难，而且你们在剧里完成得那么出色，我是做不到的。在我早年苦苦挣扎寻找角色的时候，我去试镜过多机位情景喜剧，因为
that's what you did. That's what you did. That was the majority of shows were. And I was terrible. I was terrible. I couldn't do it and I didn't understand because I was like, it's in front of a live audience. I went to theater school. It's just theater, right? But it's not just theater. It's its own art form. It's a certain kind of style. And it is to be respected. And you can do it, Angela. Not great, lady. Not great. No, you can. Much better than me. I mean, right after the office wrapped, my agents were like, let's get you on a three camera.
那是当时的常规做法。那是你必须做的。那是绝大多数剧集的模式。而我一塌糊涂。我糟透了。我做不到，我也不理解，因为我想，这不就是在现场观众面前演吗。我上过戏剧学校。这不就是演话剧吗，对吧？但它不仅仅是话剧。它有它自己的艺术形式。它是一种特定的风格。这是需要被尊重的。而且你能做到，安吉拉。演得不太好，女士。不太好。不，你可以的。比我强多了。我是说，《办公室》杀青后不久，我的经纪人们就说，让我们给你安排一个多机位喜剧吧。
And they said, do you want to do this role for Hot in Cleveland? And I was super excited. And I've told you this with Betty White, my gosh. You can't wait. I had to be the bitchy principal. This is in my wheelhouse. I just spent nine years being the bitchy principal. And I said the line and the director was like,
他们说，你想演《热力克利夫兰》里的这个角色吗？我超级兴奋。我跟你说过这个，跟贝蒂·怀特合作，我的天呐。你简直迫不及待。我得演那个刻薄的女校长。这完全符合我的拿手好戏。我刚花了九年时间扮演刻薄的女校长。我说完台词，导演说，
louder, say it louder. And then I said it louder, but then it sounded weird. And then he was like, can we get her like maybe a cane, like a cane, like she comes in like with a, and I was like, and he goes, maybe she has a hat. And Craig Ferguson was in the episode with me and we had become friends at this point. And he goes, maybe we get her a parrot and a patch.
大声点，声音大点。然后我声音放大了一点，但听起来怪怪的。接着他说，能不能给她拿根手杖，就像手杖一样，让她拄着拐杖走进来，然后我就——接着他说，也许她戴顶帽子。克雷格·弗格森当时也和我一起拍那一集，我们那时已经成了朋友。他说，也许我们给她配一只鹦鹉和一个眼罩。
Yeah, exactly. Yeah, yeah, there you go. But they're trying to sitcom it up. They were trying to like make me more of a bigger character and I had forgotten, I didn't know how to do it. Yeah, you'd gotten so used to the volume and tone level that you guys were on. It's so different.
对，完全正确。对，对，就是这样。但他们是在强行制造情景喜剧的效果。他们试图让我变成一个更夸张的角色，而我当时已经忘了、我不知道该怎么演了。对，你们已经习惯了你们剧里那种音量和基调水平。真的太不一祥了。
And I do love sketch comedy, but I think like I didn't know how to time it out with all the moving parts Well, just thank God the office came along for me because I did not thrive in the three-camera world I really tried I always thought that I was like a pretty naturally funny person and that comedy was my thing in terms of Comedy acting but I was not a fit for the three-camera style in fact the one major role that I landed was the pilot of Man with a Plan, starring Matt LeBlanc.
虽然我很喜欢小品喜剧，但我觉得我不知道该如何配合所有活动的部件来把握时机。好吧，谢天谢地《办公室》选了我，因为我在多机位喜剧的世界里根本无法大展身手。我真的很努力过。我一直以为自己是一个挺有天赋的搞笑人才，在喜剧表演方面喜剧就是我的拿手好戏，但我根本不适合多机位喜剧的风格。事实上我拿到的唯一一个重要角色是《顺其自然》的试播集，由马特·勒布朗主演。
And I was on for many, many seasons without me. Because I was fired after the pilot. Oh, geez, yeah. Yeah. That was my big job after the office was Man with a Plan. And I just struggled. I was like, why can't I do this? It is not easy.
我拍了好多好多季——没有我。因为我在试播集之后就被解雇了。哦，天哪，是的。对。那是我演完《办公室》之后接到的第一份大工作，就是《顺其自然》。而我当时举步维艰。我心想，为什么我做不到这一点？这真的一点也不容易。
And I really respect anyone who can do it. You both thrive on the office. It's amazing. Well, I wanted to say that. I think one of the reasons why the office was so successful is not just you would arguably be in the conversation for best ensemble cast on TV and mainstream TV, but there's so much heart that's unexpected.
我真的很尊重任何能做到这一点的人。你们俩在《办公室》里都大放异彩。太惊艳了。好吧，我想说的是。我觉得《办公室》之所以如此成功的一个原因，不仅在于你们可以说是电视界、主流电视界最佳群戏阵容的有力竞争者，而且里面有那么多意想不到的温情。
I remember watching an interview with your editor, who said that as he was editing the scene where Jim and Pam are on the boat for the booze cruise, that he's editing. He goes, I knew what happened. And I was still there going, kiss her. Oh. Kiss her. Come on, Jim, kiss her.
我记得看过你们剪辑师的一个采访，他说当他在剪辑吉姆和帕姆在“酒水游轮”上的那场戏时，他正在剪。他说，我知道接下来会发生什么。但我坐在那儿还是忍不住喊：亲她。哦。亲她。拜托，吉姆，亲她。
You're working on the show. Yeah. You know what's going to happen, and you're still so invested that you're yelling at the screen to have the characters kiss. That's rare in any medium, but on television at the time, it was unheard of. So we were yelling at the screen, things like that.
你明明正在参与制作这部剧。是的。你知道会发生什么，但你还是全身心投入，以至于对着屏幕大喊让剧中的角色接吻。这在任何媒介中都很罕见，但在当时的电视界，简直是闻所未闻。所以我们都会对着屏幕大喊类似的话。
Kiss her, and oh my god, and Jim can't come back from Stanford with her. Come on. And Pam's doing this when she walks across the hot coals. We were just invested in everything. And then on top of that, it was hysterical. So that was just an added bonus to the show. Was lightning in a bottle.
亲她，天呐，吉姆不能跟她一起从斯坦福回来了。拜托。还有帕姆赤脚走过红热煤炭时的那一幕。我们对一切都全身心投入。最棒的是它还爆笑无比。所以这只是这部剧的额外加分项。简直是可遇不可求的神来之笔。
I mean, it's tough to get that again. I don't know if we ever will, frankly. I mean, I don't know if I ever will. It was a dream job. Yeah. Came around at the exact right time. And I felt like I was ready. My acting coach always says, successful
我的意思是，想要再次重现这一点太难了。坦白说，我不知道我们以后是否还能做到。我是说，我不知道我以后还能不能做到。这绝对是梦想中的工作。对。在对的时间恰好出现了。而且我觉得我已经准备好了。我的表演教练总是说，成功
come when your readiness meets the opportunities. And so you can be as ready as you are and then never have an opportunity. But likewise, you can have all the opportunities in the world, which I was getting with all of my auditions for three camera shows. But I wasn't ready. And so the office for me was the thing where finally
往往发生在你准备就绪与机会相遇的时候。所以你可以准备得十分充分，但却永远没有机会。但同样地，你可以拥有一切世上所有的机会，就像我当时为所有多机位情景喜剧试镜时那样。但我还没准备好。所以《办公室》对我来说就是那个终于
the opportunity met the readiness. I think that's true for a lot of our cast too, because we had a lot of really great seasoned comedians that had just been, you know, plugging away. Kate Flannery is hilarious. She was part of a lounge act called the Lampshades. Oscar Nunez, I had met at the Groundlings. He was in Hot Towel. We had a scene together. You know, obviously, Steve Reign, everyone had been sort of putting their dues in, putting their time in,
机会与准备相遇的项目。我觉得我们的很多演员也是如此，因为我们有很多非常优秀、身经百战的喜剧演员，他们只是一直在，你知道的，默默耕耘。凯特·弗兰纳里太搞笑了。她曾是一个名为“灯罩”的酒廊表演团的成员。奥斯卡·努涅斯，我是在The Groundlings剧团认识他的。他在《热毛巾》里演过。我们一起拍过一场戏。显然，史蒂夫·雷恩，每个人都在某种程度上付出了努力，奉献了时间，
and it was just that right moment. But I have a question for you guys. Yeah. So, OK, if you could play a character on The Office, like, which one would you want to play? Oh, that's such a good question. Will, I really hope you say Dwight. Yeah, we've got to be Dwight. Comedy does actually tend itself towards Dwight.
而这一切就在那个正确的时刻发生了。但我有一个问题想问你们。好吧。那么，好吧，如果你们能在《办公室》里扮演一个角色，你们会想演哪一个？哦，这真是个好问题。威尔，我真的希望你说的是德怀特。对，我们必须是德怀特。喜剧其实确实更倾向于德怀特。
It does. You'd be Jim. Yeah. I'd be Dwight, and you'd be Pam. I'd want to be Pam. Yeah, I would have to agree with that assessment. Yeah. I would have to agree with that assessment entirely.
确实如此。你会演吉姆。对。我会演德怀特，你演帕姆。我想演帕姆。对，我完全同意这个评价。对。我完全赞同这个看法。
Now I really, really wish we had brought a Jim Pam Dwight scene with us. Yeah. We should do that next time. Which scene would you like? Yeah, which scene would you like? I next time. Which scene would you like? Yeah. We should do that. Oh, my god.
现在我真的、真的很希望我们今天带了一场吉姆、帕姆和德怀特的对手戏来。对。我们下次一定要演。你们想演哪一场？对，你们想演哪一场？我下次。你们想演哪一场？对。我们应该演那场。天呐。
Which scene would you like? No, I mean, that's definitely how I would have cast it, too, if it had to be the three of us to do it. It would have been that. So great. Is it true that there was a chance you guys were going to be canceled after the first six? Oh.
你们想演哪一场？不，我是说，如果非要让我们三个人来演的话，这绝对也是我当时的选角。肯定会是那一场。太棒了。真的假的，据说你们在头六集之后差一点就被砍掉了？哦。
Oh, yeah. Not just after the first six. The first six episodes any day when we went, we were like, oh, we're still here. Yay. That's crazy. And just after the first six. The first six episodes, any day when we went, we were like, oh, we're still here, yay. Oh, that's great. And we were not a hit. And also, NBC wasn't rallying behind us at all. No, we were very surprised to get a pickup for season two,
哦，是的。不仅仅是在头六集之后。头六集播出的每一天，当我们去上班时，我们都在想，哦，我们还活着。耶。太疯狂了。不仅仅是在头六集之后。头六集播出的每一天，当我们去上班时，我们都在想，哦，我们还活着，耶。哦，那太棒了。我们当时根本不是什么热门剧。而且NBC也根本没有在背后为我们造势。不，我们非常惊讶能续订第二季，
but the pickup for season two was only six episodes. Oh, my gosh. And then they ordered only six more. More, yeah. And then they ordered the back 12. And we ended up with 24 episodes. I mean, yeah. At the end of this six episodes, those first six,
但第二季只续订了六集。哦，天哪。然后他们又只追加了六集。更多的，对。然后他们又追加了后面的12集。我们最后总共拍了24集。我是说，是的。在那六集结束时，最初的那六集，
they printed my name on paper and they just laminated it with some Velcro and that's what was on my door. So I took my laminated piece of paper home with me. Yeah. I'll save it forever. We just thought that was it. So what episode would you then look to and say, that's the one where we knew what we were doing.
他们把我的名字打印在纸上，然后用魔术贴把它层压塑封起来，这就是贴在我化妆室门上的名牌。所以我把那张塑封的纸条带回家了。对。我要永远珍藏它。我们当时以为一切都结束了。那么你们会把哪一集视作转折点，觉得那是我们知道自己在做什么的时刻？
Everybody knew we were going to go from here. We're now a hit. This is what's going to happen. It's very clear to me as far as like the downloads, because the Christmas episode with Yankee Swap and babies playing jazz poster and Phyllis is sad of admit all of that the teapot that episode became the number one download on iTunes Okay, and so the ratings weren't there the ratings were there But this new world of like oh wait we can make money off of this other thing this Downloadable item not the cast doesn't get money for that.
所有人当时都知道我们要从这里起飞了。我们现在是热门剧了。这就是接下来要发生的事。对我来说，从下载量上来看非常清晰，因为有白色大象礼品交换的圣诞节那一集，还有贴着爵士海报的婴儿，菲莉丝为这一切感到难过的那个茶壶剧集，成了iTunes上的头号下载量单集。好吧，所以收视率当时可能没有完全体现出来。收视率其实是有的，但这是一种全新的世界，比如“哦，等等，我们可以从这个别的东西上赚钱”。这个可下载的项目——虽然演员拿不到这笔钱。
But people were watching it on their iPods, remember? And they were like, okay. Also for Yankee Swap. Yes, video iPod. Now, what about you guys? Did you always have, well, you mentioned individually you felt like you could be fired at any moment, but what about the show as a whole?
但人们在他们的iPod上观看，还记得吗？他们的反应是，好吧。也是为了白色大象礼品交换那一集。是的，视频iPod。那么你们呢？你们是否一直觉得——好吧，你们刚才提到自己个人觉得随时可能被解雇，但对于整部剧来说呢？
Yeah, we always felt like we were pretty much on the bubble. We never ever, maybe three to four or four to five, maybe one season we knew picked up for the next one. I think four and five maybe we were kind of, it was also just a weird position to be a kids show. We felt like nobody was watching, you know, like we had no cultural feedback. Like there was no online culture,
对，我们总觉得自己一直处于生死边缘。我们从来没有——也许第四季到第五季，或者第五季到第六季，只有某一个季度我们提前知道被续订了下一季。我觉得第四季和第五季时我们差不多有这种感觉，而且作为一部儿童剧，这也是一个很奇怪的定位。我们觉得根本没有人看，你知道的，就像我们没有任何来自文化的反馈。就像当时没有网络文化，
but there was also just no way that kids could, like we would get recognized, like, couldn't go to the mall. But otherwise, like as far as like the industry or we were nothing. We felt like we were getting no, you know, and so it's only now that we're like, oh, my God, we were big. Well, we also had one of our other executive puses on not not the one used to give us notes, but another one who just recently came on and said
但同样孩子们也没法——比如我们会被认出来，像不能去商场。但除此之外，就行业而言，我们根本不算什么。我们觉得我们没有得到任何，你知道的，所以直到现在我们才反应过来，“哦天呐，原来我们当时那么红”。好吧，我们剧组还有另一位执行制片人——不是那个经常给我们提意见的，而是另一位最近才加入的制片人说
that was also a network thing where they specifically didn't want you to know that you were popular so that they couldn't go and ask for more money to make the show. Right, they wanted us to feel like we were going to be there. So if you're always on the bubble, then you're lucky we're giving you this budget. So don't ask for any more because you barely got picked up. Where if we knew the show was, or they knew that the show was popular,
这也是电视台的策略，他们特意不让你知道自己有多火，这样你就不会去要求更多的片酬来制作这部剧。对，他们想让我们觉得自己随时可能被砍。所以如果你总是处于生死边缘，那你就会觉得“我们给你这点预算算你走运”。所以别再要更多了，因为你们本来就差一点没被续订。而如果我们知道这部剧很火，或者他们知道这部剧很红，
the executive producers go in and ask for the moon. So to stop that, they would kind of make us seem like we're just, we're lucky to be there. Don't forget you're lucky to be there. But also we were canceled in 2000 with what Don't forget you're lucky to be there. Also, we were canceled in 2000 with what, like a 25 share? Yeah, right. Exactly. Like, nowadays everybody would chill for that kind of audience.
执行制片人们就会去狮子大开口了。为了阻止这种情况，他们会让我们觉得自己只是、能留下来就谢天谢地了。别忘了你能留下来是走运。但我们也是在2000年被砍的，当时收视率是多少？大概25%的收视份额？是的，没错。就像，现在所有人都会为那种观众群体做梦笑醒。
But that was a big drop for us. So that was, I mean, it was like, oh my God, we're only getting a 25. Yeah, we're done. Did you feel like you got to wrap up the show? Yeah. Yeah. We got a nice, you know, we had a very nice hour long with the retrospective and where everybody moves. We really did get a chance to say goodbye. It wasn't like we were just done. And our final scene was so great.
但这对于当时的我们来说是个巨大的跌幅。所以当时的感觉就是，哦天呐，我们只有25%了。好吧，我们完蛋了。你们觉得你们有机会给这部剧画上一个圆满的句号吗？对。是的。我们有一个很棒的，你知道的，我们有一个非常温馨的、长达一小时的回顾特辑，里面展示了每个人后来的去向。我们确实得到了一个说再见的机会。这不像我们只是突然被砍了。而且我们的最后一场戏太棒了。
It was a really nice final scene. And we were all like really crying. Actually, in the classroom. We didn't rehearse it throughout the week. We just read it at table read and then shot it once in front of the audience. And that was it. And so it's us saying goodbye to Bill Daniels as Mr. Feeny and all of us just real emotion,
那真的是一场非常温馨的最后一场戏。而且我们当时都在真心实意地哭。实际上，是在那个教室里。我们在那一周里都没有排练过它。我们在围读会上读了一遍，然后在现场观众面前拍了一次就完成了。就是这样。那是我们向饰演费尼先生的威廉·丹尼尔斯告别，全都是我们真实的感情，
Brian kind of talking to each other in character. Very emotional. Wow. I'm very thankful for that. And I don't think a lot of actors get that experience. It's just you're just done. You don't get any notice. Yeah, your character doesn't get closure.
布莱恩他们彼此以角色的身份对话。非常情绪化。哇。我对此非常感激。而且我不觉得很多演员都能有这种体验。通常就是突然结束了。你根本没有任何预告。对，你的角色得不到一个结局。
You don't get closure as a group or as a crew. A lot of people just get canceled. You're just like, not but yeah, your character doesn't get closure. You don't get closure as a group or as a crew. Yeah, a lot of people just get canceled. You just like not next year, guys. You're like, oh, yeah. For me, moving into any other acting job after Boy Meets World was a shock. It was like, we're not all best friends. We're going to be together forever.
你作为一个集体或剧组也得不到一个句号。很多人只是被直接砍掉。你就只能——但对，你的角色得不到结局。你作为一个集体或剧组也得不到句号。是的，很多人只是被直接砍掉。你就只能——明年见不了啦，伙计们。你会觉得，哦，好吧。对我来说，在《男孩世界》之后进入任何其他的演艺工作都是一种文化冲击。那种感觉就像，原来我们不是所有人都是生死之交。我们不会永远在一起。
You know, like, oh, right. That is such a rare gift. Yeah. Well, I was going to say that I think that's something that our casts have in common, which is that, like Angela was saying, for a lot of the people in the office, this was really our first big job. And you're a very open vessel when it's your first big job.
你知道，就像，哦，对。那真是极其罕见的礼物。好吧，我本想说，我觉得这是我们两个剧组共同的一个特点，那就是像安吉拉刚才说的，对于《办公室》里的很多人来说，这真的是我们的第一份大工作。当你经历第一份大工作时，你是一个非常开放、毫无保留的容器。
And we all like learned together, we learned about parts of the industry together. Like none of us had ever done a junket. None of us had ever been to the up front. So to all the business stuff that goes behind the making of a show or the publicity or anything. And so we're really bonded, not just because of the show we were on, but because we kind of learned about the entertainment business together.
我们所有人都是一起学习的，我们一起了解这个行业的方方面面。我们当中没有人做过记者巡回宣传。我们也没有人去过电视网推介会。所以所有幕后的商业运作、剧集的制作、宣传或者任何事情，我们都不懂。所以我们真正地凝聚在了一起，不仅仅是因为我们演过同一部剧，更是因为我们是一起了解娱乐圈的。
Satellite media tours. Yeah, get up at 4 a.m. and talk to 25 news stations. 25 radio stations. Yeah, that have a delay, but you can't see them. You just sit there like... You just sit there like nice and you'll see them. Yeah, exactly. I'm sorry, you go ahead.
卫星媒体连线。对，早上4点起床，接受25个新闻电视台的采访。25个广播电台。对，有延迟，但你看不到他们。你只能坐在那里像……你只能坐在那里表现得很好，虽然你看不到他们。对，完全正确。不好意思，你继续。
And also, you guys must have been there for each other for just fame, like what that weird experience is like of like getting recognized and now everybody's talking. It's like a weird thing, you know, and we're so glad we had each other. Yeah, we have people come up and say this to us all the time, which is like, you look like an older version of that lady on the office.
而且，你们俩当时一定是一起经历过成名带来的那种奇怪体验，比如被人认出来，然后所有人都在议论。那种感觉挺奇怪的，你知道的，所以我们很高兴当时有彼此陪伴。对啊，经常有人跑来对我们说这样的话：“你看起来就像《办公室》里那个女人的老版。”
Oh my God. And people who we are like, that's true. You are correct. I am the older version. Older version of the older version. The older version, yes. I know. What happened?
天呐。而且我们听到时都会觉得：没错，你说得对，我确实是老版。老版的老版。没错，就是老版。天呐，怎么会这样？
Hindsight being what it is, would you have done anything else with your characters or anything different with your characters if you could go back and do it again? You know what? Yes. I maybe would not have changed Pam's hair. Really?
如果时光倒流，以现在的视角来看，如果能重来一次，你会对你的角色做任何改变吗？你知道吗？会的。我可能不会改动帕姆的发型。真的吗？
I kind of thought to change the frizzy mullet. When she started dating Jim, I said, I think she's growing as a person. And I had this whole thing in my head, character wise, that she was going to go to art school, and she's with her love now. And so maybe she's going to do more than just let her hair air dry and put it in the clip.
我当时盘算着要换掉那个蓬松的鲻鱼头。当她开始和吉姆约会时，我觉得她在作为一个人不断成长。我脑子里关于这个角色有一个完整的构想：她要去上艺术学校了，现在她和心爱的人在一起。所以她可能不仅是让头发自然风干然后夹起来。
Maybe she's just going to primp a little bit more. And then later, I became sort of sad that that sort of signature hairdo was gone. So you might see it in later seasons. I tried to bring it back. There you go. A tiny bit. But when I rewatched the show, I became somewhat sad
她可能会稍微精心打扮一下。但后来，我又开始有点怀念那个标志性的发型了。所以你在后面的剧集里可能会看到它，我试着把它带回来了。你看，就这么一点点。但当我重温这部剧时，我心里多少有点难过。
when Pam's hair changed. That's so funny. And I kind of wish that I had just let her be. You even make fun of it in one episode. Do I? Where you say, yeah, including this very old, frizzy-haired picture of me. Yes.
当帕姆的发型变了的时候。太逗了。而且我有点希望当初就别动她的发型。你甚至在其中一集里还拿这个开玩笑呢。是吗？你说了“包括这张我留着非常老气、蓬松发型的照片”。对。
When they're doing the baked beans going all the way around. When you're putting the beans on people's pictures. What does a bean mean? Someone tell Kevin what a bean means. Yeah. And Greg didn't want me to change it. He really loved it. Like, I somehow wore him down.
当时他们在大家的照片上画着烤豆子，从头连到尾。当你在别人的照片上画豆子的时候。豆子是什么意思？谁来告诉凯文豆子是什么意思。对。而且格雷格当时不想让我换发型，他是真的很喜欢。就好像我不知怎么的把他磨得没脾气了。
Well, Mindy had already worn him down. Well, this is true. I mean. Because Kelly's transformation. Yeah. So by the time you wanted it, he was like, all right. Well, this is true. Kelly's transformation. Yeah. By the time you wanted it, he was like, all right. He was like, whatever.
好吧，明迪当时已经把他磨得没脾气了。好吧，这倒也是。我是说……因为凯利的转变。对。所以等你提出想要换发型的时候，他就觉得：好吧。好吧，这倒也是。凯利的转变。对。等你想要的时候，他就觉得：好吧。他大概觉得：随便吧。
Some of that was a little bit selfish because what would happen is after work, maybe there'd be an event or something we wanted to go to. And I didn't want to go to that event with frizzy Pam hair. And so I was like, if I could be halfway there, if you could just help me a little bit. Yeah, it would be a lot easier. That's part of the rewatch is like recognizing
这里面其实也有我的一点点私心，因为经常是下班后，可能会有什么活动或者聚会我们想去。我可不想顶着帕姆那个蓬松的发型去参加活动。所以我想，如果我能省下一半时间，如果你能稍微帮我一下。对，那就会轻松很多。重温这部剧的一部分乐趣就在于意识到……
how different the lived experience is. Like the lived experience as an actor is like, I want my hair to look like my hair. I don't care about the iconography of Pam, but now that you can go back and watch it, you're like, actually that iconography was pretty great. Yeah, 100%. You can see it more like the way your producer did, right?
那种真实的生活体验是多么不同。作为演员的真实体验其实是：“我想让我的头发看起来像我自己的头发。”我才不在乎帕姆身上那些符号化的标志呢。但现在当你回看时，你会觉得：其实那些标志性的造型还挺棒的。对，百分之百。你能以更接近制片人的视角来看待它了，对吧？
Yeah. You can see the... With you, with your hair. Oh, all... Yeah, it's like, why? You know, and at the time... You said the same thing, yeah. Yes. It's like your lived experiences from really...
对。你能看出……关于你，还有你的头发。哦，全……对，就像是：为什么呢？你知道的，当时……你也说过同样的话，对吧。是的。就像是你真实的的生活体验从根本上……
It's important. And as an actor, you know, but a good actor... But for us, it was also because of how we grew up on the set. It was a little bit of control. Oh, yeah. Like, if we could go and cut our hair, then we had a little bit of control. Yeah, yeah, exactly. It's a different thing. So... But I think, like, as an actor, it cut our hair now, for us it's full on trauma. Yeah, yeah, exactly.
这很重要。作为一个演员，你知道的，但一个优秀的演员……但对我们来说，这也源于我们在片场成长的方式。这其实关乎一点点掌控感。哦，对。如果我们可以去把头发剪了，那就意味着我们对生活有了一点点掌控力。对，对，完全是这样。这是一种不同的体验。所以……但我觉得，作为演员，现在去剪头发对我们来说简直是全方位的创伤。对，对，完全是这样。
It's a different thing. But I think as an actor, it is hard to recognize, you know? What about you, Anne? I wouldn't change anything. I really wouldn't. I just, um... Would you have worn your pantyhose? Never.
这是一种不同的体验。但我觉得作为演员，很难去意识到这一点，你知道吗？安妮，你呢？我什么都不会改。我真的不会。我只是……你会穿连裤袜吗？绝不。
And I didn't. Don't you think, though, if you're being honest... I was just honest about Pam's hair. If you're being honest, and I want you all to weigh in, don't you think the character of Angela Martin would wear pantyhose? Yeah. Yes, of course.
我确实没穿。你不觉得吗，说句实话……我刚才对帕姆的发型挺诚实的。如果说句实话，我想让你们都发表一下意见，难道你们不觉得安吉拉·马丁这个角色会穿连裤袜吗？对。是的，当然会。
Right, Angela? No, no, no, no. Although, I would have to say, wouldn't pantyhose really pick up cat hair? And probably get run by cats. That's yeah. That is true. Thank cats. That's yeah. That is true.
对吧，安吉拉？不，不，不，不。不过，我不得不说，连裤袜不是很容易粘上猫毛吗？而且可能很容易被猫抓破。没错，确实如此。多亏了猫咪。没错。确实如此。
Thank you. You're right. Thank you. So maybe there's a character justification. Characterized. That was part of my character assessment. She would not spend all this extra money on pose that would just get stretched up.
谢谢你。你说得对。谢谢。所以这可能算是一种对角色的合理解读。角色设定。那是我对角色分析的一部分。她才不会把额外的钱浪费在那些很容易勾丝的连裤袜上。
You'd have to be like me today and have an extra pair in your purse in case it gets run. She also buys most of her clothes at stores where they sell large colonial American dolls. Gap kids is too flashy. Okay, this makes me want to ask you a question. What do fans ask you to sign? Is there a quote from each of your characters?
你得像我今天这样，包里随时备着一条备用的，以防万一勾丝。她大部分衣服也都是在卖那种大型美国殖民地娃娃的店铺买的。Gap Kids（盖璞童装）对她来说太花哨了。好吧，这让我想问你们一个问题。粉丝们都让你们签什么？你们各自的角色有什么标志性的台词吗？
Because I know ones that I get asked that one. Of course. I have a cat phrase. I have something called a feeny call. So I get asked to sign that quite a bit. Is that Life's Tough, Get a Helmet or the Good Looking Guy theme song from the episode you watched? Right. I wondered if you had to sign that quite a bit. Is that Life's Tough, Get a Helmet, or the Good Looking Guy theme song from the episode you watched? Right, I wondered if you had to sing that,
因为我知道别人找我签名时都会问哪些。当然。我有一句口头禅。我有一句叫“费尼式呼唤”的台词。所以我经常被要求写这个。那是“生活很艰难，戴上头盔吧”，还是你在看的那集里那个大帅哥的主题曲？对。我一直在想你是不是经常得签这个。那是“生活很艰难，戴上头盔吧”，还是你在看的那集里那个大帅哥的主题曲？对，我想知道你是不是得唱那首歌，
because I know Craig Robinson, people ask him to sing. Out of paper, out of stock. Yes, yes, yes. So yeah, no, having a catchphrase, you have to write the same. Do I? No, I was thinking you don't really have one. I get asked to do Hello, Buh-bye, I'm so with have one. I get asked to do Hello, Bye-Bye, I'm So at the Mall.
因为我知道克雷格·罗宾逊，大家老让他唱。纸张用光，库存告罄。对，对，对。所以，对啊，拥有专属口头禅的话，你就得写一样的话。是吗？不对，我以为你其实没有什么口头禅呢。大家老让我说：“哈喽，拜拜，我在商场呢。”
Yes. I get asked, Topanga says something to Corey at one point where she says, you are you and I am I, and if in the end we end up together, it's beautiful. So I get that quote. People like us to write, dream, try, do good, even though we didn't say it. Use a mirror, babe.
对。我经常被要求写下托潘加对科里说过的一句话：“你就是你，我就是我，如果最后我们能在一起，那就是最美好的。”所以我经常收到这个请求。人们喜欢让我们写：“去梦想，去尝试，去行善”，尽管这话根本不是我们说的。用镜子啊，宝贝。
Use a mirror, babe. Oh, use a mirror, babe. Use a mirror, babe. It was an episode where I walk, her first episode, she was very much a hippie. She draws with lipstick during a reciting a poem. And so I walk in and I look at her and just say, use a mirror, babe.
用镜子啊，宝贝。哦，用镜子啊，宝贝。用镜子啊，宝贝。那是剧中的一集，我走进去——那是她的第一集，她当时非常嬉皮士。她一边背诵一首诗，一边用口红画画。所以我走进去看着她，直接对她说：“用镜子啊，宝贝。”
And that was a big laugh. But that's it. I don't really have catchphrases. That's interesting. There's a little bit of an office, boy meets world crossover connection. But Will, you might be the only person who has it, which is casting director Alison Jones.
那个包袱效果非常好。但也就这样了。我其实没有什么专属口头禅。这挺有意思的。《办公室》和《男孩成长记》之间还有一点奇妙的交叉联系。不过威尔，你可能是在场唯一有这种联系的人，那就是选角导演艾莉森·琼斯。
Oh, she did our cast your pilot episode. She's a legendary casting director. Yeah, no, she wasn't on our show, and I don't even remember. I went back like five times. I don't remember her. I don't, you know. Oh, no.
哦，她负责我们试播集的选角。她是一位传奇的选角导演。对，不，她没参与我们的剧，我甚至都不记得了。我当时去了大约五次试镜。我不记得她了，真的不记得。哦，天哪。
Yeah, I know. It's too bad. So I mean, I'm sure I've met her, but yeah, I was too young to. Well, we have another connection from the episode that you actually had us watch is Hank, your security guard, played the coach on Boy Meets World. Oh, he's so fantastic.
对，我懂。太遗憾了。所以我的意思是，我确信我肯定见过她，但当时我太年轻了……好吧，从你们让我们看的这集里，我们发现了另一个联系，那就是汉克，你们的保安，他演过《男孩成长记》里的教练。哦，他太棒了！
And Matthews, B-team's doesn't get sued up for away games, is the one who plays Hank. That's amazing. You know, I hustled up the stairs. I love that scene so much when he's going between the coffee and the chair. He takes a little, like, jelly bean. That was an improv. He did a little, like, jelly bean.
而且马修斯的B队客场比赛不用穿队服，演汉克的就是他。太神奇了。你知道吗，我当时冲上楼梯。我太喜欢那个场景了，当他在咖啡机和椅子之间来回走动的时候。他顺手拿了一颗像果冻豆一样的东西。那是即兴发挥。他随手拿了一颗像果冻豆的东西。
That was an improv. He did that. And I laughed the first time he did it. That's so great. And then Steve as Michael is like, get out of here. I'm like, that's it. I can't help it. But also just when he sits in Pam's chair.
那是即兴发挥。那是他自己加的。他第一次这么做的时候我直接笑场了。太棒了。然后史蒂夫扮演的迈克尔说：“滚出去。”我就觉得：太绝了，我真的忍不住。不过还有他坐在帕姆椅子上的那个情节。
Oh my god. It just was really hard for me not to laugh. There was a few times we broke. One of the most, I would say really precarious moments of Ed breaking was his character has to take a bite of a tuna fish sandwich. Oh yeah. It's really a tuna fish sandwich.
天呐。我当时真的很难忍住不笑。有好几次我们都笑场了。要说艾德笑场时最惊险、最悬的时刻之一，就是他的角色必须咬一口金枪鱼三明治。哦，对。那真的是个金枪鱼三明治。
And then I have to go and grab one and kiss him. Yeah, I thought of that while it was happening. Yes, and Ed right before the take said, Ange, I'm not going to open my mouth at all so you don't get any of this tuna. I said, thank you. The camera couldn't see his face right as I grab him. My body's blocking.
然后我得走过去抓着他并亲吻他。对啊，事情发生的时候我就在想这个。是的，在开拍前一秒，艾德说：“安吉，我待会儿嘴巴绝对闭得紧紧的，这样你就不会沾到一点金枪鱼味了。”我说：“谢谢你。”摄像机从我抓着他的时候拍不到他的脸。我的身体挡住了。
But he'd go like this. And he would hold, because he had to hold his breath, because I wanted it to be this like, and he started to break at one point. And I'm like, and he's like, frr, frr, frr. And I'm like, no, no, no, no, no. no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, This was great. This was amazing. So wonderful. Ryder, thank you for reaching out. Of course. Thank you for responding. And suggesting it. This was so cool. It was really great.
但他会做出这样的动作。而且他得憋气，因为我希望营造出这种效果，结果他拍到中途差点笑场。然后我就听到他在那儿：哼，哼，哼。我说：“不，不，不，不……”太棒了。这简直太棒了。太精彩了。赖德，谢谢你主动联系我们。当然。谢谢你们的回复。
And it was really nice for us to be able to look you in the eyes and to thank you for paving the way for us to even have a show. And so we just, we admire you both so much. Admire what you do. Love your work, both podcast and TV. So thank you for everything. Well, thank you. Thank you. Well, I will be getting your phone number for future Office Ladies.
并且提出了这个建议。这太酷了。真的太棒了。而且能够看着你们的眼睛，感谢你们为我们铺平了道路，让我们甚至能拥有一档属于自己的节目，这对于我们来说真的非常美好。所以我们真的、真的很崇拜你们俩。崇拜你们所做的一切。非常喜欢你们的作品，无论是播客还是电视节目。所以谢谢你们做的一切。好吧，谢谢你们。谢谢你们。好了，为了以后的《办公室女士》播客，我得弄到你的电话号码。
That's the problem. Hit me up. Well, let you know what happened on your show. OK, thank you. Thank you. Well, that was so much fun. They are so fun, lady. They really are. I'm so glad we did that. I'm so glad that Ryder suggested it.
这就是问题所在。联系我吧。好吧，随时让我们知道你们节目有什么新动向。好的，谢谢。谢谢。好吧，刚才真的太好玩了。她们太有趣了，女士们。真的太有趣了。我很高兴我们做了这个节目。我很高兴赖德提出了这个建议。
Yeah. I love just hearing about their journey becoming podcasters and rewatching their show. Yeah. It was really cool. I loved it. Well, listen, everybody. Head over to Pod Meets World because we
对。我特别喜欢听他们讲述自己成为播客主以及重温自己节目的心路历程。对。真的很酷。我太喜欢了。好了，听着，各位。请前往《播客成长记》，因为我们
did part one of this collaboration where Pod meets office ladies. We watched an episode of Boy Meets World and we talked all about it. Yes, we watched Hair Today, Goon Tomorrow, and neither of us had seen it. And we talked all about it and we learned a lot of behind the scenes details.
进行了这次合作的第一部分，即“播客遇见办公室女士”。我们看了一集《男孩成长记》，并对此展开了热烈的讨论。是的，我们看了《今日发型，明日暴发》，我们俩之前都没看过那一集。我们对此进行了全方位的探讨，并且了解了很多幕后花絮。
Yeah, they gave us a quiz too. And I mean. You won. I did well. Anyway. You did. All right, you guys, go listen to that and hope you have a great week. See you next week.
对，他们还给我们出了个测验。而且我的意思是……你赢了。我表现得挺好。总之。你确实表现得不错。好了，各位，去听那一期吧，祝你们度过愉快的一周。我们下周见。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz.
感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是Audience（奥德赛）的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的执行制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。奥德赛频道的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带制作。
Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿创作的《鲁珀特之树》。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。